I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everyone. Hi. Today is Golden Ticket, season five, episode 19. This was written by Mindy Kaling and directed by Randall Einhorn. It's a big day for Michael. Oh, it's a big idea for Michael. It's a big idea day for Michael. Here's your summary. Michael decides to execute a Willy Wonka-themed promotional idea. He is going to take some golden tickets.
我是珍娜·菲舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们为你带来了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当事两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士们。大家好。嗨。今天是第五季第十九集《金奖券》。这一集由明迪·卡林编剧，兰德尔·艾因霍恩导演。对迈克尔来说，这是个大日子。哦，对迈克尔来说是个伟大的构想。对迈克尔来说是个重大构想的日子。这是剧情梗概。迈克尔决定实施一个以《查理和巧克力工厂》为主题的促销活动。他打算拿出几张金奖券。
He's going to hide them in some paper shipments. And any company that finds a golden ticket gets 10% off. And it's not limited to one. Well, we're going to find that out. Yeah. This idea is going to backfire. He is going to pressure Dwight into taking the fall. But then that backfires. Yeah. A lot of ideas and a lot of backfires. A lot of layers here playing games. Yeah. Meanwhile, Pam, Jim, and Andy are all giving dating advice to Kevin. It's somewhat conflicting. Kevin's a little confused, but he's going to try to make a connection with Lynn from Blood Drive from their Lonely Hearts mixer. Lynn is still in the mix from the mixer. Yeah. Let's get into fast facts. Fast fact number one, this episode
他要把它们藏在一些纸张出货单里。任何找到金奖券的公司都可以享受九折优惠。而且不限于一张。好吧，我们待会就会知道了。是的。这个想法将会适得其反。他打算逼德怀特当替罪羊。但随后这也适得其反了。是的。有很多想法，也有很多适得其反。这里有很多层次，大家都在玩心眼。是的。与此同时，帕姆、吉姆和安迪都在给凯文提供约会建议。这些建议多少有些矛盾。凯文有点糊涂了，但他打算通过他们的失恋者联谊会，去联系一下“血源”里的林恩。林恩依然是联谊会的目标。是的。让我们进入快讯环节。快讯第一条，这一集
contains maybe one of the most famous office GIFs of them all. You know what I'm talking about. A GIF for a GIF. It doesn't matter. You know the one we're talking about. Is it GIF or GIF? I don't know, guys. I've never known. I'll never know. Let's ask the two hip young people in the booth. Please, young people, tell us how to say it. I say GIF. What do you say? No, I say GIF. Sorry. I think the correct one is GIF, but it feels wrong. But everyone I know says GIF. It's kind of like GIF, but you take the T off. So I think it's GIF. Well, I've been saying GIF. I say GIF. There you have it. Also, what's a meme? A GIF is if it moves and a meme is if it's still. People say GIF is correct, but keep
包含的可能是有史以来最著名的《办公室》GIF动图之一。你知道我在说什么。GIF还是JIF，无所谓。你知道我们说的是哪一个。是发GIF的音还是JIF？我不知道，伙计们。我从来都不知道。我永远也不会知道了。让我们问问隔音间里的两个赶时髦的年轻人吧。拜托，年轻人，告诉我们该怎么发音。我说GIF。你呢？不，我说GIF。抱歉。我觉得正确的读音是GIF，但听起来不对。不过我认识的人都说GIF。有点像GIF，但把最后的T去掉。所以我觉得是GIF。好吧，我一直说GIF。我说GIF。答案这不就有了吗。还有，什么是梗图？如果会动，那就是GIF；如果是静止的，那就是梗图。人们说GIF是正确的，但请记住
in mind it stands for Graphics Interchange, whatever the F is. So it starts with a G. So it would be GIF, right? Graphics, G. Yeah. There it is. Okay. We'll put a poll, but okay. GIF is a peanut butter. I'm just saying. I like it. You know. I don't know. Well, you're putting a poll and since I brought it up, are you a crunchy or a smooth peanut butter? Smooth. Same. Get your peanuts out of my peanut butter. So there is a very famous GIF. Or GIF. Oh, I said it wrong again. Well, we don't know if you're saying it wrong, lady, but it's true. When Dwight looks at camera and has his hand up to his face. It's at the end of the cold open and he says, it's true. That's everywhere. It even made it to USA Today's
它代表的是“图形交换”（Graphics Interchange），随便管它F是什么吧。所以它以G开头。所以应该是GIF，对吧？Graphics，G。是的。就是这样。好吧。我们会发起一个投票，不过好吧。GIF是一种花生酱。我只是随口说说。我喜欢它。你知道的。我不知道。好吧，既然你要发起投票，而且是我挑起的话题，你喜欢颗粒状的还是幼滑的花生酱？幼滑的。一样。把你的花生酱从我的花生酱里拿开。所以这里有一个非常著名的GIF。或者GIF。哦，我把发音又说错了。好吧，我们不知道你是不是说错了，女士，但这是真的。当德怀特看着镜头，把手举到脸上时。这出现在冷开场的结尾，他说，这是真的。这到处都是。它甚至登上了《今日美国》
ranking of the top 36 GIFs of the office. It's true was number 13. What's number one? Number one. That's what she said. No, that's on the list, but it's not number one. Number one was Michael from the Super Bowl cold open when he says, oh my God, it's happening. Oh, okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh, that's stress relief. Stress relief. Yeah, where they're doing the fire drill. Yes. Do you want to know what number two is on their list? Is one of my favorites. It might be my number one. Don't throw garbage at my head. No, it's Kelly. It is. I have a lot of questions. Number one, how dare you? Oh, yeah, that's a good one. But I would like to say that number 12 was Jim and Pam's air high five. We made it on
《办公室》最佳36个GIF排行榜。“这是真的”排在第13位。那第一名是什么？第一名。那是她说的。不，那在榜单上，但不是第一名。第一名是来自超级碗冷开场的迈克尔，当时他说，哦，我的天呐，要发生了。哦，好吧。对，对，对。哦，那是《减压》。《减压》。是的，他们在那做消防演习。是的。你想知道他们的榜单上第二名是什么吗？是我的最爱之一。这可能是我的第一名。别往我头上扔垃圾。不，那是凯利。是的。我有好几个问题。第一，你怎么敢？哦，对了，那个不错。不过我想说，第12名是吉姆和帕姆的空中击掌。我们上了
the list. So I'm proud of us. I don't know that Angela Martin is on the list with dialogue, but I'm on every list. If you type in I roll, you've got an I roll. I've got an I roll and I've got a real good one in this episode. I'm going to point out fast fact. Number two, speaking of the cold open, which gave us this famous gift, it's all about knock, knock jokes. The guys are doing these knock, knock jokes with each other and we'll break it down fully when we get there. So I watched this episode with Lee and he said, isn't it amazing how the knock, knock joke is so universal that if one person walks up to another person and says knock, knock, you just know to say who's there. Yeah. And then you know you're in a
榜单。所以我为我们感到骄傲。我不知道安吉拉·马丁是否带着台词上了榜单，但我每一个榜单上都有。如果你输入“翻白眼”，你就会看到一个翻白眼。我有一个翻白眼，而且我在这一集里有一个非常棒的。我要指出快讯。第二条，说到给我们贡献了这幅著名GIF的冷开场，这完全是关于敲门笑话的。大伙们互相讲着这些敲门笑话，等我们聊到那儿时会全面剖析。所以我跟李一起看这一集时，他说，敲门笑话竟然如此具有普遍性，这难道不神奇吗？如果一个人走向另一个人说“敲敲”，你就会自然而然地知道要接“是谁”。是的。然后你就知道你在
knock, knock joke. How did that begin? Well, uh-oh, somebody hit the Google button. Yes. As a lady who Googles, I'm going to give you the history of knock, knock jokes. I want to hear it. So the first written coupling of knock, knock who's there. The first time it sort of appeared anywhere people believe is Shakespeare's Macbeth. All roads lead back to Shakespeare. That's why it was so important to study it in theater school. Hey, I studied Shakespeare. I believe you. But I studied it in my writing class. Well, there you go. Act two, scene three, the porter is very hungover and he has this monologue where he repeats knock, knock who's there and then he tells you who's there. He's sort of just kind of
讲敲门笑话了。这究竟是怎么开始的？好吧，哦哦，有人按了谷歌按钮。是的。作为一个爱用谷歌搜索的女士，我来给你们讲讲敲门笑话的历史。我很想听听。所以最早有文字记载的“敲敲，是谁”的组合。人们认为，它最早出现在莎士比亚的《麦克白》中。条条大路通莎士比亚。这就是为什么在戏剧学校里研究它如此重要。嘿，我学过莎士比亚。我相信你。但我是我的写作课上学的。好吧，原来如此。第二幕，第三场，看门人宿醉得很厉害，他有一段独白，里面反复说着“敲敲，是谁”，然后告诉你是谁在敲门。他有点像在
in his head. Tis I am on to you. But in this play, it is not a joke. He's not doing like a jokie thing. It's not like what it is now. So now cut to, it's the early 1900s and there's this new kind of comedy on the scene. Ooh, what kind? It's like a call, answer comedy or like a bait and response comedy. And here's an example of one of these jokes from the 1900s. Someone would say, do you know Arthur? And that would make the other person say Arthur who? And then you would say Arthur monitor. Yes, that was one of the jokes. My kids would love that one saving it. Well, it's very similar to that whole up dog joke. The what's up dog? I don't know what's up with you. Right, right. That Michael famously botched. So then in
自己琢磨。正是我，我盯上你们了。但在戏剧中，这并不是一个笑话。他不是在搞什么搞笑的事。它不像现在这样。现在，把镜头切到20世纪初，当时出现了一种新喜剧。哦，什么类型的？有点像呼应式喜剧，或者说是一种抛接回应式喜剧。这里有一个20世纪这种笑话的例子。有人会说，你认识亚瑟吗？这会引得另一个人说，哪个亚瑟？然后你会说，亚瑟监控器（Arthur monitor）。是的，那是其中一个笑话。我的孩子们会喜欢这个，我得留着。好吧，这跟那个“什么梗”（up dog）的笑话非常相似。那个“怎么了，狗狗？”我不知道，你有什么新鲜事？对，对。迈克尔把这个梗给搞砸了。所以呢，在
the mid 1930s, this kind of like pun mania morphed into what is now the traditional knock knock joke. Cartoonist Bob Dunn is credited with inventing this joke in its current form. He wrote a book called knock knock who's there. And it's basically filled with knock knock joke puns. It sold like 2 million copies. It took off like crazy. It was a jeopardy question. Like this. What? Knock knock jokes were especially huge in Pennsylvania. Oh, versions of knock knock jokes started appearing in advertisements. The Edgemont cash and carry grocery store in Chester, Pennsylvania ran an ad that said knock knock who's there Don Don who Don forget to do your shopping at the cash and carry. Yeah, Don forget it. There was also this one
20世纪30年代中期，这种双关语狂热演变成了现在传统的敲门笑话。漫画家鲍勃·邓恩被公认为是以目前的形式发明了这种笑话。他写了一本名为《敲敲，是谁》的书。里面基本上都是敲门笑话的双关语。它卖出了大约200万册。它火得一塌糊涂。它还成了《危险边缘》节目里的问题。就像这样。什么？敲门笑话在宾夕法尼亚州尤其火爆。哦。各种版本的敲门笑话开始出现在广告中。宾夕法尼亚州切斯特市的埃奇蒙特现金自选杂货店登了一则广告，上面写着“敲敲，是谁？唐。唐是谁？唐（别）忘了去现金自选店买东西。”是的，唐忘了。还有一个
ready knock knock who's there Rufus Rufus who roof is the most important part of your house. That was a roofing company. Okay. But politicians started using them. There were like special clubs called knock knock clubs that formed in Illinois and Iowa and Kansas. And I guess knock knock clubs you would just go there until your knock knock. Yes, it was like a place to have a drink and share your greatest knock knock jokes. Then in 1936 at like the peak of the knock knock joke craze, there was a song called the knock knock song by Fletcher Henderson and I'm going to play you a clip. Oh my word. Yeah, I love it. A whole song full of knock knock jokes. So then, lady, there is a backlash. Oh, people turn
准备好了吗？敲门，是谁？鲁弗斯。鲁弗斯是谁？屋顶（Roof is）是你房子最重要的部分。那是一家屋顶公司的广告。好吧。但政治家们也开始使用它们。伊利诺伊州、爱荷华州和堪萨斯州甚至成立了名为“敲门俱乐部”的特殊俱乐部。我想去敲门俱乐部的话，你只要一直去，直到你敲门……是的，那就像是个可以喝一杯并分享你最棒的敲门笑话的地方。然后在1936年，也就是敲门笑话狂热的巅峰时期，有一首由弗莱彻·亨德森演唱的歌叫《敲敲歌》，我要放一小段给你们听。我的天哪。是的，我太喜欢了。整首歌都是敲门笑话。然后呢，女士，出现了一阵强烈的反弹。哦，人们开始
on the knock knock. Well, all of these psychologists start coming out like Sigmund Freud. Oh, and a April they start saying that people who have an incessant need to make puns have a psychological condition. Oh, no, that it is like a sign of narcissism. Oh, a German neurologist named Fried Forster said manic punning was a certifiable syndrome and he actually called it Forster syndrome. He named it after himself. Aren't you being a narcissist, Mr. Forster? I mean, I don't know. You're telling me that people that love and pun are narcissists and then you name it after yourself. That's right. I just want to point that out. Yeah. Well, despite their best efforts, knock knock jokes have stayed around. We still have them today.
反感敲门笑话了。好吧，所有这些心理学家开始出现，比如西格蒙德·弗洛伊德。哦，在四月份，他们开始说那些对讲双关语有着不可遏制需求的人患有某种心理疾病。哦，不，这被认为是自恋的迹象。哦，一个名叫弗里德·福斯特的德国神经学家称狂热说双关语是一种确诊的综合征，他实际上把它命名为福斯特综合征。他用自己的名字给它命名。福斯特先生，你不觉得自己很自恋吗？我是说，我不知道。你告诉我说那些喜欢双关语的人是自恋狂，然后你用你自己的名字给它命名。没错。我只想指出这一点。好吧，尽管他们尽了最大努力，敲门笑话还是流传了下来。我们今天依然在使用它们。
Of course, they appear in this episode of the office. Halloween is coming up. That's when I always hear the knock knock jokes. I think it's like with kids. Yeah. What do you got? What do you got? Knock knock. Who's there? Boo. Boo who? Don't cry. It's just a joke. Got it. Do you have any that are like, what are your favorites? Well, this is the one I remember from elementary school. Knock knock. Who's there? Banana. Banana who? Knock knock. Who's there? Banana. Banana who? Knock knock. Who's there? Banana. Banana who? Knock knock. Who's there? Orange. Orange who? Aren't you glad I didn't say banana? I remember that one too. This is my kid's favorite. What? Knock knock. Who's there? Interrupting cow. Oh, my kids
当然，它们也出现在这一集的《办公室》里。万圣节快到了。每到那时候我总能听到敲门笑话。我觉得这就像是对小孩子来说的。是的。你有什么？你有什么？敲门。是谁？布（Boo）。布是谁？别哭，这只是个笑话。懂了。你有什么……比如，你最喜欢哪个？好吧，这是我从小学起就记得的。敲门。是谁？香蕉。哪个香蕉？敲门。是谁？香蕉。哪个香蕉？敲门。是谁？香蕉。哪个香蕉？敲门。是谁？橘子。哪个橘子？难道你不同意我刚才没说香蕉吗？我也记得那个。这是我孩子最喜欢的。什么？敲门。是谁？打断人的牛。哦，我的孩子们
like this one too. I know that one. Interrupting cow. So the lady has Googled, we have gotten to the bottom of the knock knock joke. What's your Fast Facts number three? My Fast Facts number three is that supposedly coming out in November 2021, there is going to be a Michael Scott Funko Pop holding a golden ticket. Oh, is it going to be dressed like Willy Wonka? Yeah, he's going to have a little top hat on. I saw their rendering for it and I don't know how accurate it is, but they're saying this is going to be a new Funko Pop based on this episode. Well, that's so fun. I just think they're all so cute. I'm about to get one of Angela and her Fun Run outfit. You know, I don't have a single Pam Funko Pop.
也很喜欢这个。我知道那个。打断人的牛。既然这位女士已经用谷歌查过了，我们已经弄清了敲门笑话的来龙去脉。你的第三条快讯是什么？我的第三条快讯是，据说在2021年11月，将会推出一款手里拿着金奖券的迈克尔·斯科特Funko Pop手办。哦，他会打扮成威利·旺卡的模样吗？是的，他会戴着一顶小礼帽。我看到了他们为此设计的渲染图，我不知道它有多准确，但他们说这将是一款基于这一集的新款Funko Pop。哇，太有趣了。我只是觉得它们都太可爱了。我正打算买一个穿着“趣味跑”服装的安吉拉呢。你知道的，我没有一个帕姆的Funko Pop手办。
Come on. I don't have one. You got to get one. I guess I do. I have one of me and my cat and now I'm going to have the Fun Run one, but that's so cute. The Willy Wonka one is going to be so cute. Well, if you're into merch from this episode, I also found that you can buy a frameable golden ticket just like the one that Michael is putting in the boxes. It was on Amazon. Oh, I don't know why you would want that, but if you do, it is available. If you're having a Willy Wonka themed party. Oh, yeah. Maybe. I was curious, do you think Michael is being the Gene Wilder Willy Wonka or the Johnny Depp? I think he's Gene Wilder. That's what I thought too, but Gene's blazer
拜托。我一个都没有。你得去买一个。我想我确实得买。我有一个我和我猫咪的手办，现在我又要有了“趣味跑”那个，这太可爱了。威利·旺卡那个肯定也会超可爱。好吧，如果你喜欢这一集的周边，我还发现你可以买到一个可以装裱的金奖券，就像迈克尔放进盒子里的那个一样。亚马逊上有卖。哦，我不知道为什么你会想要那个，但如果你想要的话，它确实买得到。如果你要举办一个以威利·旺卡为主题的派对。哦，对。也许吧。我很好奇，你觉得迈克尔扮演的是吉恩·怀尔德版的威利·旺卡，还是强尼·德普版的？我觉得他是吉恩·怀尔德。我也是这么想的，但吉恩的西装
is purple and Johnny Depp's is maroon and Michael's is maroon. But he's doing all the somersaults and the dialogue from the Gene Wilder. I agree. I agree. Those are all my fast facts. We're going to go to a break and when we come back, we have a delicious surprise. We have a guest. Yes. Oh, we can't wait to talk to him. Oh, I gave a little bit away. Okay. It's a guy. He's tall. And his name is also a weather condition. All right. We'll leave you guessing and then we'll be back. Is someone on the phone? Hi, it's me, Rainn Wilson. Rainn Wilson. Rainn, what are you doing? Why are you calling us?
是紫色的，强尼·德普的是栗色的，而迈克尔的是栗色的。但他做了吉恩·怀尔德所有的前滚翻动作，台词也是吉恩·怀尔德的。我同意。我同意。这些就是我所有的快讯。我们要去休息一下，回来后，我们会有一个美味的惊喜。我们有一位嘉宾。是的。哦，我们迫不及待想跟他聊天了。哦，我稍微透露了一点。好吧。是个男的。他很高。而且他的名字也是一种天气现象。好啦。我们留着让你们去猜，一会儿就回来。有人在打电话吗？嗨，是我，雷恩·威尔逊。雷恩·威尔逊。雷恩，你在干嘛？你为什么给我们打电话？
Well, I just wanted to see how you guys doing. I missed you. I missed you. I just want to know if you want to hang out. Oh, I do want to hang out. I would like to hang out. Great. So when are we getting together? You tell us. You know what we want to do, Rainn, for reals. We had this on the text thread. We want to come to your house and listen to Creed and her son play guitar together. And I want to see your new place and I want to meet your pigs and your Zonky. Have you heard about our newest pet sensation? No. Oh, the peacock. We have Alma the peacock. And now Rainn, did she just walk on up or did like, how did Alma get there?
好吧，我只是想看看你们过得怎么样。我想你们了。我想你们了。我只是想知道你们想不想一起出去玩。哦，我确实想出去玩。我很想出去玩。太好了。那我们什么时候聚聚？你们来定。雷恩，你知道我们真心想做什么吗。我们在群聊里说过这个。我们想去你家，听克里德和她儿子一起弹吉他。我还想看看你的新住所，我想见见你的猪和杂交斑马。你们听说我们最新的宠物明星了吗？没有。哦，孔雀。我们有一只叫阿尔玛的孔雀。雷恩，它是自己溜达过来的，还是说……阿尔玛是怎么来的？
So my wife had a horse for a long time named Gus. And Gus was a very old white liposon horse and he passed away this summer. He lived a rich, full horse life and he died very quickly. So that was all fine. But his stall was empty and they put a vase of flowers in there and it was just kind of left empty as a kind of a salute to old Gus. And two weeks later, no joke, and Gus was white, by the way. Two weeks later, out of nowhere, sitting in Gus's horse stall was a white peahen, a female peacock. Oh my goodness. No one knows where it came from. It had never been seen there previously. It hadn't been seen in the neighborhood or the area of where my wife's horse, where
我妻子以前有一匹马叫格斯。格斯是一匹很老的白色利比扎马，它今年夏天去世了。它过着丰富充实的马生，而且它走得很快。所以一切都还好。但它的马厩空了，他们在里面放了一束花，就那样空着，算是对老格斯的一种致敬。两周后，不开玩笑，而且格斯是白色的，顺便说一句。两周后，毫无征兆地，坐在格斯马厩里的竟然是一只雌孔雀。哦，天哪。没人知道它是从哪来的。以前从没在那里见过它。在附近或者我妻子骑马的那个区域也都没见过它。它就这么直接搬进了格斯的马厩。于是她就训练它吃饲料，但它不能一直呆在那，因为它会吓到一些马，因为孔雀会拍打翅膀并发出叫声。所以她训练它吃饲料，然后把它诱进一个搬运箱里，我们把它带回了家，它非常完美地完成了过渡。你们知道吗，阿尔玛太棒了。它白天在不捉虫子的时候就会睡觉。它就睡在我办公室窗户外的橄榄树上，整天盯着我看。所以如果我在做播客、开Zoom会议或者别的什么，我就会有一只白孔雀盯着我的办公室。
she rides her horses. And it just moved in to his stall. And so she kind of trained it to eat feed and it couldn't stay there because it was spooking some of the horses because they would flap around and squawk. So she trained it to eat feed and go into a carrying container bin and we took it to our house and it made the transition perfectly. And you guys, Alma is amazing. And she sleeps during the day when she's not hunting bugs. She sleeps in the olive tree right outside my office window and just stares in at me all day. So if I'm like podcasting or on Zoom calls or whatever, I have a white peacock staring into my office.
雷恩，这正是我梦寐以求的。我对我的蜂鸟就很激动了。如果我的树上有一只孔雀，我肯定会疯掉的。我是说，雷恩，这太酷了，这就是格斯，对吧？我的朋友说，如果还需要更多转世投胎的证据的话。现在，我不知道……我不知道我是否相信转世，但我的意思是，这太神奇了。这是一次神奇的经历。这有点疯狂。好吧，那儿确实发生了点什么。是的，我是说，不管你信不信转世，宇宙中刚好就在那里发生了如此美妙的事情。是的。是的。所以除了现在住在我们家的那些猪，我们现在还有了一只要求很高的孔雀。我妻子霍莉简直疯了。她买了一大箱东西昨天刚送到，我打开一看，里面装满了。我没开玩笑。里面装满了面包虫。讨厌。两大箱二十磅重的面包虫袋子。你把这些放在哪儿？是的。你怎么冷藏它们？
This is all I could ever hope for, Rain. I'm excited about my hummingbirds. If I had a peacock in my tree, I'd lose it. I mean, Rain, it's so cool, it's Gus, right? My friend said if there was ever more proof needed for reincarnation. Now, I don't know about, I don't know that I buy reincarnation, but I mean, it was magical. It's a magical experience. It's kind of crazy. Well, there's something happening there. Yeah, I was going to say, whether you believe in reincarnation or not, there's just something
上帝救救我们吧。就像……你拿面包虫怎么办？你怎么把面包虫安顿好？你只要把它们撒在地上，然后它就吃面包虫。但吃虫子的间隙……不是我妻子，是孔雀。孔雀。我们懂了。好吧，雷恩，听着，你能来我们太兴奋了。我们知道你以前来过，
beautiful in the universe that happened right there. Yeah. Yeah. So besides now our pigs that live at our house, now we have a peacock who is very demanding. Holly, my wife just went crazy. She bought like a big box arrived yesterday and I opened it up and it was filled. I'm not kidding you. It was filled with mealworms. Ew. Two like 20 pound boxes of bags of mealworms. Where do you keep those? Yeah. How do you refrigerate them?
你还发过音频剪辑，你总是那么支持我们。但我们意识到，有些非常常规的问题我们通常会问嘉宾，而我们从来没有对你做过这个。这就是我们一贯的开场问题。准备好了吗？来吧，问吧。好的。那么，你是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？听说你最初是为迈克尔·斯科特这个角色试镜的，这是真的吗？给我们讲讲你的《办公室》起源故事吧。哦，我有一个极棒的《办公室》起源故事。我特别喜欢讲这个故事。太精彩了。我当时刚开始拍《六尺之下》这部剧，我正处于那部剧的刚起步阶段。那是HBO开始腾飞的时候，那是一部备受赞誉的剧集。而我当时被选中参演ABC的一部由珍妮·加罗法洛主演的喜剧试播集。而且，你知道，那是一个非常小的角色，但我想，嘿，你知道的，这是一笔惊人的片酬。这太棒了。我要成为剧集常规演员了。这是我第一次真正尝试成为剧集常规演员的工作。对于那些正在收听并想知道的人来说，这比客串演员赚的钱多得多。我对此感到非常兴奋。鲍勃·奥登科克参演了，马克·马龙也参演了，演员阵容真的很棒。我当时正走去进行剧本围读。等等，那叫什么名字？你知道它的名字吗？哦，天哪，我会想起来的。我现在记不起来了。哦，真实生活，静物，诸如此类。我会查一下的。我记不起来了。当时我正在去参加剧本围读的路上，这是演员们常做的事，你会在片场进行剧本围读，或者以前经常这么做，大家围坐在桌子后面，大声朗读剧本，所有高管都在场，这样他们就能一起观察演员阵容，感受他们的能量，听听朗读的节奏，给出意见等等。非常常见的场景。在路上，我遇到了一个当时认识的NBC高管，我以前见过他几次。我……我忘了为什么。我说，哦，嗨，那是弗农，弗农·桑德斯。我们都喜欢弗农。是的。对，对。他现在在亚马逊。是个好人。我说，嗨，弗农。他说，嗨。就问，最近怎么样？他说，哦，我太兴奋了，因为我们刚刚买下了BBC版《办公室》的版权。我以前看过几集。我的朋友萨姆通过一个在英国的人用录像带录了下来。那是在它们在美国播出之前。那是很早以前。我看过，而且我非常喜欢。我在心里和表面上都说，哦，太棒了，太棒了。但在心里我想的是，哦，该死。我一定要演那部剧。那部剧太棒了。所以我当时想，好吧，回头见。然后去参加剧本围读。这是最不可思议的经历之一。事实上，肯·茨沃纳克（Kent Zvornak）就是那部剧的制片人。哦，天哪。哇，肯百科全书？是的。所以我们进行了剧本围读，这是一次声名狼藉的活动。我们进行了剧本围读。结果太糟糕了，项目当场就被叫停了。他们取消了它。他们甚至都没有拍摄。他们连布景都搭好了。我们连机票都买好了。酒店房间都订好了。我本该第二天早上飞过去，然后过个两两天就开始拍摄。结果剧本围读进行得太糟糕了。顺便说一句，我们找到那个名字了，名字叫《生活切片》（Slice O Life）。《生活切片》。我就知道里面有“生活”和“S”。所以突然之间，我有空去演《办公室》了。所以我打电话给我的经纪人。我说，我真的很想去试镜这个《办公室》。是的，我是第一天第一个去试镜的人。选角导演艾莉森·琼斯从《六尺之下》和其他一些事情中对我有点了解。我太兴奋了。我在第一天同时为德怀特和迈克尔这两个角色试镜了。她一直威胁说要公开发布我试镜迈克尔·斯科特的视频。那真的是糟透了，因为我只是在模仿瑞奇·热维斯。我不知道还能做什么。所以我一直在扯我的领带。而且，但是德怀特，我很清楚，我想，这完全符合我的特长。我太清楚这个人是谁了。这家伙简直刻在我的基因里。我有表亲跟德怀特·舒鲁特真的差不了多少，剩下的就是历史了。
God save us. Like what, what do you do with the meal? How, where do you put a mealworm? You just put them in on the ground and then she eats the mealworms. But in between eating. Not my wife, the peacock. The peacock. We got that part. Well, Rain, listen, we're so excited to have you on. We know you've been on before and
雷恩，我记得在试镜时我们被分在了一组。是的。他们把我们打乱重新组合。当时大概有4个帕姆，4个吉姆，4个德怀特和几个迈克尔。鲍勃·奥登科克就是其中一个迈克尔，这太疯狂了，因为我猜他也有空，既然《生活切片》没有继续拍下去的话。肯·茨沃纳克也有空。是的。哇。我们真的从《生活切片》剧组挖来了好多人。真是走运。我们赚到了。但雷恩，我记得我和你分在了一组。而且，我的天，我简直不敢相信。在我们所有人当中，从一开始，你就百分之百地融入了角色。我觉得从我和你进行第一次试镜场景的那一刻起，对于其他人——我当时跟约翰分在了一组，我想，哦，是的，这很棒。还有史蒂夫和所有人。但雷恩，你当时就……我都不知道雷恩从哪里开始、德怀特在哪里结束，或者德怀特从哪里开始、雷恩在哪里结束。我的天，那种融为一体的感觉太惊人了。不过，我得说，我们之间是互相崇拜的。对于那些不知道的人，珍娜当时完全进入了帕姆的状态，简直是帕姆附体。你当时在读一本关于约翰·贝鲁西的书《疯狂连线》（Wired），你觉得帕姆会读这本书。剧本里写了她在读这本书。所以我把整本小说都读了。我把整本书都读完了。我想：既然我的角色读了，我也得读。是的。而且你在候诊室里也是帕姆。但是，那真的太好玩了。我们有……我不知道他们有没有公开发布过那个试镜视频，但那场即兴表演中，我当时只是坐着……我跪着离你近得有点过分。就像……这是德怀特非常喜欢做的事，就是他完全没有个人空间的观念。他根本没有。所以他可以跟一个人贴在相距只有四英寸的地方说话。我一直觉得这真的很好笑。我还谈到我的女朋友驻扎在科威特。那真的很好笑。然后你只是……那是一场极棒的即兴表演，因为大多数演员觉得，哦，我在即兴表演，我需要说很多话。你知道，他们以为即兴表演就是说很多话。而这是一场即兴表演，我差不多做了这段独白，而你只是痛苦地凝视着虚空，默默承受着我的体味、我们之间的距离以及我故事的古怪。这太棒了，太绝了。当我们完成那场试镜时，我想，哦，我知道我们肯定能演这些角色了。是的，我当时也有这种感觉。而且在那种试镜中，我很清楚地感觉到，你就是他们的不二人选。他们是不是一直在让不同的人跟雷恩搭档？因为这就是你如何能看出来的方法，你知道的，当他们说，“哦，让我们看看他跟这个人、这个人还有这个人搭档会怎样”时，那个人就是最终人选。
you've sent in audio clips and you're always so supportive. But we realize there are just some real general questions we ask our guests and we never got to do that with you. And here is the one we always lead with. Are you ready? Okay. Hit me. All right. So how did you get your job on the office? Is it true that you first audition for the role of Michael Scott? Tell us your office origin story. Oh, I have a great office origin story. I love to tell the story. It's fantastic. I was starting to do this show six feet under and I was just at the very beginning of that,
而我只跟他搭档过一次。这让我有点紧张，因为我很清楚雷恩已经稳拿这个角色了。所以我当时想，哦，好吧，大家基本上只能想象我和很多不同的吉姆搭档的画面。我记得自己和很多不同的吉姆一起读过剧本。他们说最终选择约翰的原因是——显然，他又迷人、帅气、幽默、擅长面无表情地抖包袱、聪明得要命，而且活力十足——但他的体型跟我差不多。还有另外几个吉姆身高只有五英尺七英寸。那样的话，德怀特的气场就会完全压倒他们。而吉姆实际上比我还高。所以我们俩在能量上真的很搭。
of that show. And that was right when HBO was starting to take off and it was a very widely highly regarded show. And I got cast in this Jeanine Garofalo comedy pilot for ABC. And, you know, it was a very small role, but I was like, Hey, you know, it's an amazing paycheck. This is great. I'm going to be a series regulars. My first like real stab at a series regular job. And which is a lot better money than doing a guest star, just for those who are listening and wondering. And I was very excited about it. Bob Odenturk was in it. Mark Marin was in it at a really kind of great cast. And I was walking to the table read. Wait, what was it called? Do you know the name of it? Oh, boy, it'll come
我觉得这说得通。是的，确实如此。但后来他们在你的感情线上走了截然不同的路线，他们选择了办公室里体型最娇小的人。最娇小、最娇小的细胳膊细腿。是的，但我认为他们当时并不知道德怀特和安吉拉会走到一起。他们只是……我不知道那个剧情走向是怎么来的。但我猜他们在第二季时只是在摸索，想着，“哦，我们得把事情搞出点新花样。”因为一开始他们让我和凯利在一起，他们让我吻了凯利·卡普尔。但安吉拉气坏了。安吉拉看了之后气炸了。还记得吗，他们让我看着镜头，他们让我看起来……他们一直说“要更多愤怒，更多愤怒”。
to me. I can't remember right now. Oh, real life, still life, something like that. I'll look it up. I can't remember. And I was on the way to the table read, which is something that actors, you do at the studio or you used to do, you all sit in a room behind the table and you read it out loud and all the executives are there so they can kind of see the cast together, get their energy, hear the rhythms of the read, give notes etc. Very common occurrence. On my way there, I ran into this NBC executive that I knew at the time, who I had met a couple times. I don't, I forget why. And I was like, Oh, hi, it was Vernon, Vernon Sanders. We love Vernon. Yes. Yeah, yeah. He's an Amazon now. And a nice guy. And I was like,
我当时想，哦，天呐，我的眼珠子都要从眼眶里瞪出来了。但我认为我们的编剧只是坐在那儿。珍娜和我讨论过这个，我们也和编剧们探讨过，他们是如何把两个名字写在卡片上，然后看看那种组合会产生什么感觉，并就这两个人能从对方身上激发出什么特质进行一番即兴探讨。没错。这也是格雷格谈到过的一点，而且对于喜剧编剧和编剧来说，这是一个非常棒的经验教训。他说，很多剧集真的很专注于某一个角色，比如，“哦，让我们把这个角色塑造得非常具体、有趣、引人注目。”但他的重点其实是当这两个角色碰撞在一起时——
hi Vernon. And he's like, hi, it's like, what's going on? And he goes, well, I'm so excited because we just landed the rights to the BBC office. And I had seen a couple episodes. My friend Sam had them recorded from someone in England on a VHS. It was before they were like available in the United States. It was really early on. I had seen them and I just loved them. And I, and inside and outside, I was like, Oh, that's great. That's great. And inside I was like, Oh, God damn it. I want to be in that show. That's so, that show's so awesome. And so I was like, okay, see you later. Went to the table read. This is one of the most incredible experiences. In fact, Kent Zvornak was the producer on it. Oh my
那是她说的。然后那种能量会发生什么变化，你知道的，所以他更关注角色之间的互动动态。我认为这也是《办公室》成功的原因之一。好吧，我们今天讨论的这一集《金奖券》里，有着经典的迈克尔和德怀特的组合。我真的很喜欢在这部重温播客中，看到德怀特既能当迈克尔的马屁精，同时又能当面质问他、敢于顶撞他。对你来说，那是一种什么样的体验？你和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔以这种喜剧二人组的形式合作了七年，演绎了许多这样的时刻。那种经历是怎样的？
gosh. Wow, Kentopedia? Yeah. So we did the table read and this was an infamous event. We did the table read. It went so bad that the plug was pulled immediately. They canceled it. They didn't, you didn't even shoot it. They did not shoot it. They had sets built. We had plane tickets. We had hotel rooms booked. I was supposed to fly the next morning and then start shooting in like two days. And the table read went so poorly. We found the name, by the way, the name is Slice O Life. Slice O Life. That's what I knew it had life in it and an S. But so all of a sudden I was free to do the office. So I called my agents. I was like, I'd really like to audition for this office. And yes, I was, I was the first
好吧，这其实是一堆问题。我知道……我喜欢这样采访别人。她总是喜欢抛出大概13个宏观的、涵盖一切的巨大问题。一下子全抛出来。我太喜欢了。好吧，让我来回答那个。让我先说，每当我回想起和史蒂夫一起工作的经历时，我都充满感激，因为他显然是有史以来最伟大的演员、喜剧演员之一，甚至可以说是最伟大的演员之一。我能和他进行那么多合作，简直是一份巨大的恩赐。我并非出身于即兴喜剧背景。我其实很擅长即兴表演，但我上的是戏剧学校，我演过莎士比亚，演过尤金·奥尼尔，我是纽约那种外外百老汇剧场出身的演员。而史蒂夫
person to audition on the very first day. Alison Jones, the casting director kind of knew me from 16 under and some other things. I was so excited. And I auditioned for both Dwight and Michael on that first day. And she keeps threatening to release my Michael Scott audition. It is truly terrible because I just did a Ricky Gervais impersonation. I didn't know what else to do. So I was kind of pulling on my tie a lot. And it was, but Dwight, I knew I was like, this is completely in my wheelhouse. I know exactly who this person is. This guy is in my DNA. I have cousins who are really not that different from Dwight Schrute and the rest is history. Well, Rain, I remember being paired with you during the
出身于“第二城”（Second City），做过多年、多年、多年的即兴表演。所以那是他的强项。但关于史蒂夫，你知道的，人们总是把它变成一种陈词滥调，就像即兴表演中的“好，而且……”（yes and）。比如，如果你说，“嘿，我买了一只宠物孔雀。”然后你顺着说“好，而且我很想看看它。我能喂它吃我的面包虫吗，诸如此类？”无论我做什么，史蒂夫在这方面都表现得不可思议。有时候我会尝试做一些非常不着边际的举动。史蒂夫会完全以角色的身份做出反应，并接受所提出的设定。所以我可以……因为显然我们会拍摄一个场景。我们会即兴发挥——我是说，我们会按照剧本演。我们会拍摄剧本内容，确保台词完全按剧本演好。然后我们会即兴发挥。有时我们就会完全自由发挥，彻底放飞自我。我记得我会说一些诸如“我决定开一家美洲驼农场”之类的话，完全是凭空冒出来的。而史蒂夫就会以迈克尔的身份去听，把这话听进去，然后说：“等等，你在说什么？美洲驼？什么？这跟任何事有什么关系？为什么？你太奇怪了，德怀特。走开，你真恶心。”诸如此类的反应，而且这完全是即兴当下的反应。我从这个过程中学到了太多。他从来没有那种“该死，雷恩。你为什么这么奇怪，这么傻？回到场景的重点上来”的情绪。我们可以完全偏离主题，（离题）十万八千里。而他总是能立刻接上。能跟他合作真是一种特权。我太喜欢了。我特别喜欢那种会议室的场景。显然迈克尔有他的目的和要说的话。而你，作为德怀特，竟然会插话打断，对吧？雷恩，有好多好多次我去查阅剧本，想看看那是剧本写的还是即兴发挥的，因为我觉得我现在能分辨出来了。而且那些桥段总是那么精彩。但它们是天衣无缝的。你根本分不清，正是因为你刚才分享的原因：不管你插嘴说了什么，史蒂夫作为迈克尔，总是能顺着你的话演下去。这绝对是一件让人极其快乐的事。你知道的，我是一个书呆子气的即兴表演迷。我们在播客里聊过，你和珍娜都有过那种“我们学过戏剧”的经历。珍娜喜欢提醒我这一点，雷恩，就像你做的那样。但作为一个书呆子气的即兴表演迷，看着你们俩的表演，简直太棒了。我觉得自己就像坐在第一排，欣赏着一些真正神奇的时刻。说到具体的《金奖券》这一集。谢谢你，安吉拉。不过说真的，自从它播出以来，我还没看过这一集。看这一集真的太有趣了。珍娜，就像你说的，德怀特那种奴颜婢膝、拍马屁、极度渴望得到迈克尔认可的动态，和后来他诡异地意识到自己其实手里有点权力时的转变……你知道的，当他在握着大卫·华莱士的手说“谢谢你”并把功劳揽到自己身上时。然后史蒂夫那个表情，简直无价之宝，一副“哦，这家伙”的样子。还有你们俩在营销会议上的争吵，当你们跟营销人员通电话时，你们俩你来我往地抛出你们的宏大构想。是的，马形船。还有所有关于厕所、厕所、厕所的网兜，想出了很多关于厕所的点子。你们根本没有好点子。不，我有的。我很想看到那一幕的加长版，因为我敢打赌，我们在那个场景中来回抛出了更多点子。我们应该去问问大卫·罗杰斯，也就是所有花絮素材的守护者，因为我敢打赌你说得对，当时肯定还有更多的点子。另外，
screen tests. Yeah. And they were mixing and matching us. There were like four PAMs and four gyms and four Dwights and a few Michaels. Bob Odenkirk was one of the Michaels, which is so crazy because I guess he was available as well since Sly So Life didn't go forward. And Kintz and Renak was available. Yeah. Wow. We really got a lot of folks from Sly So Life. Got lucky there. We scored. But Rain, I remember being paired with you. And I, I mean, I couldn't believe it. Of all of us, of all of us, you were 100% there from the beginning. I feel like from that moment that I did that first audition scene with you, everybody else, I was like, I was paired with John and I was like, oh, yeah, this is great. And Steve and
这一集是由明迪·卡林编剧的，她非常擅长现场即兴发挥，当场给你塞一些额外的东西。我必须告诉你们，在剧本里，我重读了一遍，帕姆试图插话提出一个想法。什么？是的。迈克尔和德怀特把她给驳回了。他们俩唯一意见一致的就是帕姆的想法太蠢了。当他们在疯狂大喊各自的构想时，帕姆弱弱地说了一句：远程控制马桶。然后他们俩都说：那太蠢了。说不通。太逊了。这太棒了。我真希望他们能保留这个情节。雷恩，我们还有一个以前从未问过你的问题。这是一个很受欢迎的问题。我们会问所有的嘉宾。好吧。尽管问吧。好的。那么当剧集杀青时，你从片场拿走过什么东西吗？哦，这太让我心碎了。我当时应该多拿点的。我本该把NBC环球给搜刮干净的。我拿走了德怀特的眼镜。我拿走了他那块写着“德怀特·舒鲁特”的小桌牌。我拿走了他的订书机。还有一两样我记不太清的东西了。我得四处找找看。但我当时列了一长串东西交给了菲尔·谢伊。我说，菲尔，帮我把这些留着。我回头来找你拿。你知道的，比如德怀特的公文包、这个那个还有别的乱七八糟的东西。菲尔当时就说，好的。然后我去找菲尔，他说，哦，我没有留着，或者我拿不到，抱歉，云云。然后我从别人那里听说。他们说，哦，他们
everybody. But Rain, you were just like, I didn't even know where Rain began and Dwight ended or Dwight began and Rain ended. I mean, it was so fluid. It was amazing. But you were, I have to say, there's a mutual admiration society. For those who don't know, Jenna was totally in PAM, Drustus PAM. You were reading the book on John Belushi, Wired, that you thought PAM would be reading. It was in the script that she was reading it. So I read the whole novel. I read the whole thing. I was like, my character read it. I'll read it. Yeah. And you were PAM in the waiting room too. I, but that was so much fun. And we had, I don't know if they'd ever released that audition, but that improvisation where
大家。但是雷恩，你当时就像是，我甚至分不清雷恩从哪里开始、德怀特到哪里结束，或者德怀特从哪里开始、雷恩到哪里结束。我是说，那种感觉太流畅了。太惊艳了。但你，我不得不说，你们俩有一种互相崇拜的氛围。对于那些不知道的人来说，珍娜当时完全代入了帕姆，杜斯特斯的帕姆。你在读那本关于约翰·贝鲁什的书《有线电视》，你觉得帕姆会读这本书。剧本里就写了她在读这本书。所以我读了整本小说。我把整本都读完了。我当时想，我的角色读了它。那我也读。对。而且你在候诊室里也是帕姆。我，但这真的太有趣了。而且我们，我不知道他们有没有发布过那个试镜片段，但是那个即兴表演是
I was just sitting, I was kneeling like way too close to you. Like, which is something I love to do as Dwight is like, he doesn't have an understanding of like, personal space. He does not. So he could be talking to someone like four inches away from them. And I thought, I always thought that was really funny. And where I talked about my girlfriend being stationed in Kuwait. And that was very funny. And you just, and it was such a great improv because most actors feel like, Oh, I'm improving. I need to talk a lot. You know, they think like, Oh, improvisation means talking a lot. And this was an improv where I kind of did
我当时只是坐着，我跪得离你太近了。就像，这是我作为德怀特很喜欢做的事，他完全没有个人空间的观念。他确实没有。所以他可以跟一个离自己只有四英寸远的人说话。而我当时觉得，这真的非常搞笑。我还谈到我的女朋友被派驻到科威特。那真的非常搞笑。而你只是，而且那真是一次非常棒的即兴，因为大多数演员都会觉得，哦，我在即兴发挥。我需要说很多话。你知道，他们会觉得，哦，即兴发挥意味着说很多话。而这次即兴表演是我做出了
this monologue and you just gazed painfully into space, taking in my body odor and my proximity and the strangeness of my story. And it was, it was fantastic. And when we did that, I was like, Oh, I know that we're going to have these parts. Yeah, I felt that way too. And I felt at that audition, it was very clear to me that you were their choice. Do they keep pairing different people with rain? Because that's how you know, you know, that's the person when they're like, Oh, let's see him with this person and this person and this person.
这个独白，而你只是痛苦地凝视着虚空，忍受着我的体味、我和你的距离以及我故事的诡异。这真的，真的太棒了。当我们完成那个表演时，我当时就想，哦，我知道我们肯定能演这些角色。是的，我当时也有同感。而且在那个试镜时，我非常清楚地感觉到，你就是他们的选择。他们是不是一直在给雷恩搭配不同的演员？因为这就是你如何知道的，你知道那就是对的人，当他们说，哦，让我们看看他和这个人、这个人还有这个人搭戏。
And I only got paired with him once. And that made me a little nervous because it was very clear to me that rain had the part. And so I was like, Oh, well, can I mostly imagine me with a lot of different gyms? I remember reading with a lot of different gyms. And the reason they said, ultimately, they went with John. I mean, obviously, he's charming and handsome and funny and great deadpan and smart as hell and like a ball. But that his size was comparable to mine. There were a couple other gyms that were like five foot seven. And it just seemed like Dwight would just overpower them. The gym was actually taller than me. So we kind of like, we really matched up kind of energy wise.
而我只和他的搭过一次。这让我有点紧张，因为我很清楚雷恩已经拿下这个角色了。所以我当时想，哦，好吧，只能想象我和很多不同的吉姆搭戏了。我记得和很多不同的吉姆读过剧本。他们最终选择约翰的原因，我是说，很明显，他迷人、英俊、搞笑、擅长面无表情的幽默，而且聪明得要命，就像个活宝。但是他的体型和我很相当。还有另外几个吉姆身高只有五英尺七英寸。这就显得德怀特会完全压倒他们。那个吉姆实际上比我还高。所以我们俩，我们在能量上真的很契合。
That makes sense to me. Yeah, that does. But then they went a whole other way with your romantic life and they picked the tiniest person in the office. Tiniest, tiniest little sprig. Yeah, but I didn't think they knew that Dwight and Angela were going to get together. They just were, I don't know where that storyline came from. But I imagine they were just kind of floundering in season two, like, Oh, we got to mix things up. Like, because at first they had me together with Kelly, they had me kiss Kelly Kapoor. But Angela was furious. Angela watched it and was furious. Remember, they had me like look in the camera like they made me look so like they kept saying more anger, more.
这对我来说说得通。是的，确实如此。但随后在你的浪漫生活上，他们走了完全不同的路线，他们选择了办公室里身材最娇小的人。最娇小、最细小的小嫩枝。对，但我觉得他们当时并不知道德怀特和安吉拉会走到一起。他们只是，我不知道那个故事情节是从哪里来的。但我猜他们在第二季时有点在盲目摸索，比如，哦，我们得把事情搞出点新花样。因为一开始他们让我和凯利在一起，他们让我吻了凯利·卡普尔。但安吉拉气坏了。安吉拉看了之后气炸了。记得吗，他们让我看着镜头，就像他们让我看起来，他们一直说要更多的愤怒，更多的。
I was like, Oh my God, my eyes are going to pop out of my head. But I think our writers just sat there. Jenna and I have talked about this and we've talked to our writers about it, how they would just take two names and put them on a card and just see what that felt like and sort of spitball a little bit about what those two people would bring out of each other. Right. And that is one thing that Greg's talked about. And I remember and it's really great lesson for comedy writers and screenwriters. He said a lot of shows really focus on a character and like, Oh, let's make this character really specific and funny and interesting. But he was really about like when these two two characters bang
我当时想，哦天哪，我的眼珠子都要瞪出来了。但我觉得我们的编剧就坐在那里。珍娜和我讨论过这个，我们也和编剧讨论过，他们如何把两个名字写在卡片上，然后看看那种感觉如何，并大致讨论一下这两个人能从对方身上激发出什么特质。对。这也是格雷格曾经谈到过的一点。我记得这对于喜剧编剧和编剧来说是一个非常棒的经验。他说很多剧集真的很专注于一个角色，比如，哦，让我们把这个角色塑造得非常具体、有趣和引人注目。但他真正看重的是当这两个角色发生
up against each other. That's what she said. Then what do what happens with that energy you know, so it was more about he was much more about dynamics between characters. And I think that's one of the successes of the office. Well, this episode that we're talking about today, Golden Ticket has a classic Michael Dwight pairing. And we just I love in this rewatch, watching the way that Dwight can be both Michael's lackey. And then also like you can take him to task you stand up to him. What was that like for you? You were in this comedy duo with Steve Carell for seven years playing out moments like this. What was that experience?
碰撞时。这正是她说的。然后会发生什么，那种能量会怎样，你知道，所以他更关注的是角色之间的动态。我认为这也是《办公室》成功的原因之一。好吧，我们今天要谈论的这一集，《黄金门票》里有迈克尔和德怀特经典的组合。而且我们，我在这遍重温中，非常喜欢看德怀特既能当迈克尔的走狗，同时又能质问他、敢于顶撞他。对你来说，那是什么样的体验？你和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔一起出演这个喜剧二人组七年，演绎这样的时刻。那段经历是怎样的？
Well, that's a bunch of questions. And I know I I that's how I like to interview people. She just likes to throw like 13 big overarching, like huge questions. All at once. I love it. Well, let's let me hit that one. Let me just say that, you know, when I look back on that work with Steve, I'm just so grateful because he's obviously like one of the greatest actors, comedy actors, but even just actors like ever. And the fact that I got to do so much work with him was just such a gift. I didn't come from an improv background. I was always good at improv, but I went to theater school and I did Shakespeare and I did Eugene O'Neill and I was in New York kind of off off Broadway theater guy. And Steve
好吧，这是一堆问题。而且我知道，我就是喜欢这样采访别人。她就是喜欢一下子抛出13个宏大的、贯穿始终的巨大问题。一下子全抛出来。我太喜欢了。好吧，让我来回答那一个。让我先说，每当我回想起和史蒂夫一起工作的那段时光，我都充满感激，因为他显然是史上最伟大的演员、喜剧演员之一，甚至可以说是最伟大的演员之一。能有机会和他做那么多合作，简直是一份厚礼。我并不是即兴表演出身。我虽然一直很擅长即兴，但我上的是戏剧学校，我演过莎士比亚，演过尤金·奥尼尔，我是纽约那种外百老汇剧场的人。而史蒂夫
was from Second City and had done years and years and years of improv. So that was his thing. But the thing about Steve that you know, they always have this kind of become a cliche like the yes and, you know, like an improv. If you say like, Hey, you know, I bought a pet peacock. Then you say yes and and like, Oh, I'd love to see it. Can I feed it my mealworms or whatever? And Steve was incredible at that, no matter what I did. And I sometimes I would try to go really out of the box. Steve would completely react in character and and accept what was being proposed. So I could just in the because obviously we would we would shoot a scene. We would improvise. I mean, we would do the script.
来自第二城剧团，做过多年、多年、多年的即兴表演。所以那是他的专长。但关于史蒂夫，你知道，他们总是把这变成一个陈词滥调，比如“是的，而且”，你知道，就像在即兴表演中。如果你说，嘿，你知道，我买了一只宠物孔雀。然后你说“是的，而且”，比如，哦，我很想看。我能用我的面包虫喂它还是怎么着？史蒂夫在这方面简直不可思议，无论我做什么。有时我会尝试做出非常跳脱常规的举动。史蒂夫会完全以角色的身份做出反应，并接受所提出的设定。所以我就可以在——因为显然我们会拍一场戏。我们会即兴发挥。我是说，我们会按照剧本演。
We would shoot the script and make sure we got it scripted correctly. And then we would improvise. And then sometimes it would just we just freely improvise and just go off. And I remember just being like, I could say something like I decided to open a llama farm just out of nowhere or something. And Steve would just listen as Michael take that in and be like, wait, what are you talking about? Lamas? What? What does that have to do with anything? Why? You're so weird, Dwight. Go away, you're icky. Like, and it would just be completely in the moment. And I just learned so much from that process. He never got kind of like, God damn it, rain. Why are you being so weird and so silly? Like stay on the point
我们会按照剧本拍摄，确保我们准确完成了剧本内容。然后我们会进行即兴发挥。有时候我们就会完全自由发挥，彻底放飞自我。我记得我会说一些诸如“我决定开一家美洲驼农场”之类的话，完全是凭空冒出来的。而史蒂夫就会以迈克尔的身份认真倾听，然后说，等等，你在说什么？美洲驼？什么？这跟任何事有什么关系？为什么？你太怪了，德怀特。走开，你真让人恶心。就像这样，而且完全融入在当下的情境中。我从那个过程中学到了太多。他从来没有那种类似“该死，雷恩。你为什么这么怪异、这么幼稚？保持场景的重点”
of the scene. And we can go way off filter, you know, way off the path. And he would just be right there all the time. It was really a privilege to work with him. I loved it when there'd be a conference room scene. And clearly Michael had an agenda and things to say. And you, you as Dwight of all people would interject, right? And rain so many times I go to the script to see if it was written or improvised because I feel like I can tell now. And they're always so good. But but it's like seamless. You would never know because of exactly what you just shared because Steve is Michael, no matter what you piped up and said, just like would just take it and run with it. And it was always like
我们可以完全偏离主线，你知道，偏离轨道。而他随时都能稳稳接住。能和他一起工作真的是一种特权。我特别喜欢有会议室的戏份。很明显，迈克尔有他的议程和要说的话。而你，偏偏是你作为德怀特会插话，对吧？雷恩，我好多次去看剧本，想确认那是写好的还是即兴的，因为我觉得我现在能分辨出来了。而且它们总是那么精彩。但感觉就像天衣无缝一样。你根本分不清，正是因为你刚才分享的那一点——因为史蒂夫就是迈克尔，无论你突然冒出什么话，他都能直接接过去顺着演下去。而且那总是
an absolute joy. You know me, I'm a nerdy, nerdy improv gal. We've talked on the podcast that you and Jenna had your whole like we did theater. And Jenna likes to remind me of it rain much like you did. But as like a nerdy improv gal watching you guys, it was it was just awesome. I felt like I had a front row seat of just some really magical moments. And getting specifically to golden ticket. Thank you, Angela. And but yeah, I hadn't seen this one since it came out. And it was so fun to watch. And Jenna, just like you said that dynamic of Dwight being toady, lackey, suck up, just so desperate for Michael's approval. And then oddly, realizing he's got some power here. And, you know, that switch
绝对的快乐。你了解我，我是一个书呆子气的即兴表演迷。我们在播客里聊过，你和珍娜都有过“我们演过戏剧”的经历。而且珍娜就像你一样，很喜欢提醒我这一点。但作为一个书呆子气的即兴迷，看着你们俩，那简直太棒了。我觉得自己就像拥有了一个前排座位，能欣赏到一些真正神奇的时刻。具体谈到《黄金门票》。谢谢你，安吉拉。不过是的，自从它播出以来我就没看过这一集了。看这个真的太有趣了。珍娜，就像你刚才说的，德怀特那种奴颜婢膝、拍马屁、极度渴望得到迈克尔认可的动态。然后奇怪的是，他意识到自己在这里握有一些权力。然后，你知道，那个转变
when he's shaking David Wallace's hand and he says, you know, thank you and takes the credit for it. And then Steve's expression of I was so priceless of like, Oh, that guy and then your fight in the marketing meeting, like when you get on the phone with the marketing guys, the two of you back and forth with your big ideas. Yeah, horse boats. And all the toilet, toilet, toilet net, get a lot of toilet ideas. You don't have ideas. Yes, I do. I would love to see an extended cut of that because I bet that there were a lot more ideas we tossed back and forth in that scene. We should ask Dave Rogers, the keeper of all of the extra footage, because I bet you're right, there had to have been even more. Also,
当他与大卫·华莱士握手，并说，你知道，谢谢你，然后把功劳揽到自己身上时。接着史蒂夫那个无价的表情，仿佛在说，哦，这家伙。然后你们在营销会议上的争吵，比如你们和营销人员通话时，你们两个针锋相对地提出那些宏大的想法。是的，马船。还有所有的厕所、厕所、厕所网，想出了很多关于厕所的点子。你们没有点子。不，我有。我真想看那一集的加长版，因为我敢打赌，我们在那个场景里抛出了更多来回碰撞的点子。我们应该问问戴夫·罗杰斯，所有额外素材的守护者，因为我敢打赌你是对的，肯定还有更多。还有，
this one was written by Mindy Kaling, and she was amazing at coming up with on the fly in the moment extra stuff to hand you. I have to tell you guys in the script, I reread it. Pam tries to butt in with an idea. What? Yes. And Michael and Dwight shoot her down. The one thing they agree on is that Pam's idea is so stupid. She says, as they're yelling all their ideas, Pam meekly just says, remote control toilets. And they're both like, that's stupid. Doesn't make sense. That's dumb. That's great. I wish they were to kept that. We have another question that we've never asked you, Rain. This is a popular one. We ask all our guests. Okay. Did you take anything from set when the show wrapped? Oh, this breaks
这一集是明迪·卡aling写的，她在现场即兴想出额外的东西交给你这方面简直太厉害了。我必须告诉你们，在剧本里，我重新读了一下。帕姆试图插话提出一个想法。什么？是的。而迈克尔和德怀特直接把她否决了。他们唯一意见一致的就是帕姆的点子太蠢了。当他们在大喊各自的点子时，帕姆弱弱地说了句：“遥控马桶。”然后他们俩都说：“太蠢了。没道理。真傻。”这太棒了。我真希望他们保留这一段。我们还有一个从未问过你的问题，雷恩。这是一个很热门的问题。我们会问所有嘉宾。好的。剧集杀青时，你从片场顺走什么东西了吗？哦，这太让我
my heart. I should have taken so much more. I should have fleeced NBC universal. I took Dwight's glasses. I took his little desk plate that said Dwight's shrewd on it. I took his stapler. And one or two other things I can't quite remember. I have to look around and see. But I had a whole list of things I gave to Phil Shea. And I said, Phil, pull these aside for me. And I'll get them from you later. And it was, you know, Dwight's briefcase and this and that and the other thing and blah, blah, blah. And Phil was like, okay. And then I went back to Phil and he's like, Oh, I don't have them or I couldn't get them. Sorry, blah, blah, blah. And then I heard from someone else. They were like, Oh, they
心碎了。我本该拿更多东西的。我本该狠狠薅一把NBC环球的羊毛。我拿了德怀特的眼镜。我拿了他那个写着“德怀特的精明”的小桌牌。我拿了他的订书机。还有其他一两样我记不太清了。我得四处找找看。但我列了一长串清单交给了菲尔·谢伊。我对他说，菲尔，帮我把这些挑出来留着。我过会儿找你拿。那是，你知道的，德怀特的公文包、这个那个还有别的等等等等。而菲尔当时说，好的。然后我去找菲尔，他说，哦，我没有，或者我拿不到。对不起，巴拉巴拉。然后我从别人那里听说，他们说，哦，他们
threatened the crew to be fired and never work for NBC universal again, if they caught them taking anything from the office. And we didn't know why. And then they had that big auction where they auctioned all the stuff off on eBay, you know, even like Dwight's desk was auctioned off. Did you not get your bobble head? I got one of the rejected bobble heads that doesn't look anything like the bobble head. I did not get my original bobble head. No, I see. That's a shame. And I have Phil Shea for the painting. The Dwight painting is kind of where he's like Chairman Mao. Yeah, yeah. And that didn't happen either. Well, Rain, you know, you've gone on to do so many awesome
如果被抓到从办公室拿走任何东西，就会威胁剧组人员被解雇，而且再也不能为 NBC 环球工作。我们当时不知道为什么。后来他们办了一场大型拍卖会，在 eBay 上拍卖了所有的东西，你知道的，连德怀特的办公桌都被拍卖了。你难道没有拿到你的摇头娃娃吗？我拿到了一个被淘汰的摇头娃娃，它看起来一点也不像那个摇头娃娃。我没有拿到我原本的那个摇头娃娃。没关系，我懂。真可惜。这幅画我是从菲尔·谢伊那里买的。德怀特的这幅画有点像他是毛主席的感觉。对，对。后来也没发生那种事。不过，雷恩，你知道的，你后来做了那么多出色的
things, but we would love to talk to you about your podcast, Metaphysical Milkshake. I listened to a great episode last night when you had Mike Sherron. Yeah. And that was so amazing just talking about what is good, what is bad. And he sort of like folded in his show The Good Place into that episode. But you and Reza are so thoughtful. And you're really asking life's big questions. And it's a great listen. Yeah, thanks. Well, you guys know this is something that's always been really important to me. And it was kind of the impetus and inspiration for starting Soul Pancake, a digital media company that I created with some friends. But this whole idea of life's biggest possible
事情，但我们很想聊聊你的播客《形而上学的奶昔》（Metaphysical Milkshake）。我昨晚听了一集很棒的节目，你请到了迈克·谢尔（Mike Sherron）。对。那真的太棒了，聊了什么是善，什么是恶。他甚至把他的剧集《善地》（The Good Place）融入了那一集。但你和礼萨（Reza）真的很有深度。你们真正在探讨人生中的重大问题。而且非常值得一听。对，谢谢。好吧，你们知道这对我来说一直是件非常重要的事情。这也算是创办“苏尔煎饼”（Soul Pancake）的契机和灵感，这是我和一些朋友共同创立的数字媒体公司。但关于人生中最大可能的
questions has always really intrigued me. You know, I took philosophy in college and I love studying spirituality and I love psychology and sociology and kind of creativity and how creativity works and why. And so this was kind of the foundation for Metaphysical Milkshake. Our first season we did on this company called Luminary, but that didn't really work out. So now we're doing a second season, which is available wherever podcasts are available and including a lot of the stuff we did for our first season. And it's super fun. We get to talk to just artists and thinkers and writers. We just yesterday interviewed Avi Loeb, who's the head of the Astronomy Division of Harvard University, talking about alien life and discovering
各种问题这个宏大概念，一直让我深深着迷。你知道的，我在大学里修过哲学，我喜欢研究灵性，我喜欢心理学、社会学以及某种程度上的创造力，还有创造力是如何运作的以及原因何在。所以这可以说是《形而上学奶昔》的基础。我们的第一季是在一家叫 Luminary 的公司做的，但后来不太顺利。所以我们现在正在做第二季，大家可以在各大播客平台上收听，其中也包括很多我们为第一季制作的内容。这真的超级有趣。我们能和各种艺术家、思想家和作家对话。就在昨天，我们采访了哈佛大学天文学系主任阿维·勒布（Avi Loeb），谈论了外星生命和发现
extraterrestrial life. And then we had Jason speaking of office auctions. Jason Isbell is one of my favorite kind of country rock. I love him. Yeah, he's so great. Yeah, he came on the show talking about like what music is, like where does music come from? Oh, I need to go listen to that one. He bought years ago, he bought his wife's white scissors from the NBC auction. Whoa. Isn't that crazy? Yes. Well, Rain, I listened to your interview with Adam Grant, where you discussed this concept. What if I'm wrong? And this idea our resistance as people to consider that you might be wrong, or even what I loved when you guys talked about how when you know you're wrong, but the cost of admitting you're wrong,
外星生命。然后我们还请到了杰森——说到办公室拍卖——杰森·伊斯贝尔（Jason Isbell）是我最喜欢的乡村摇滚歌手之一。我太喜欢他了。对，他太棒了。对，他来到节目中聊了什么是音乐，音乐是从哪里来的？哦，我得去听听那一集。他多年前从 NBC 的拍卖会上买了他妻子的白色剪刀。哇。是不是很疯狂？是的。好了，雷恩，我听了你对亚当·格兰特（Adam Grant）的采访，你们在节目中讨论了这个概念：如果我错了怎么办？还有这种作为人类抗拒去思考你可能会错的想法，甚至我最喜欢的是你们讨论当你知道自己错了，但承认自己错了的代价时，
that idea of like, there's that social cost, oh no, if I admit I'm wrong once, people will paint me with a brush that, oh, that's the person who gets things wrong. I mean, it was just, it was so thoughtful. I love that kind of introspective discussion that makes me think about things that maybe I wouldn't have thought of otherwise. It's a great podcast. You know, I'm glad you brought that one up because I feel like this is kind of where our country is. It's very stuck in two sides that are convinced they're 100% right and no one's really talking to each other and learning and listening from each other. And when you go to life's biggest questions, these are the questions that we've been asking
那种社会成本的概念，哦不，如果我承认自己错了哪怕一次，人们就会给我贴上标签，认为“哦，这就是那个经常把事情搞砸的人”。我的意思是，这真的太深刻了。我喜欢那种能引发内省的讨论，它能让我思考一些平时可能不会去想的事情。这真的是个很棒的播客。你知道的，我很高兴你提起那一集，因为我觉得这正是我们国家目前的现状。它深深地陷入了两个阵营的对立中，双方都坚信自己百分之百正确，没有人在真正地互相交流、学习和倾听彼此。而当你探讨人生中最大的问题时，这些正是我们从
since the caveman days, since ancient Greece, why are we alive? Do we have free will? What's the meaning of it all? And these discussions can unite us. So that's really the whole purpose is to unite people by getting young folk thinking about talking, wrestling with the human experience. Well, Rain, at the end of your podcast with Reza, you guys do this sort of rapid fire of questions. And I love when you ask people, when do you most feel connected to the universe? I'm paraphrasing, but it's something like that question, right? So when do you rain feel most connected to the universe? Wow, you're okay, you're hitting me with my own weapon. That's what she said. That's a profound question. And wow, no one's ever asked me
穴居人时代、古希腊时期以来一直在追问的问题：我们为什么活着？我们有自由意志吗？这一切的意义是什么？这些讨论能够团结我们。所以这其实就是全部的目的：通过让年轻人思考、讨论、并与人类体验作斗争，来把人们团结在一起。好了，雷恩，在你的播客与礼萨共同主持的结尾，你们会进行一组快问快答。我特别喜欢你问别人：你什么时候最能感受到自己与宇宙的连接？我是用自己的话在复述，但大概就是类似的问题，对吧？那么雷恩你是什么时候最能感受到自己与宇宙的连接的呢？哇，好吧，你这是在用我自己的武器来攻击我。这话她也说过。这是一个很有深度的问题。而且，哇，从来没有人问过我
that before. So I meditate, that's part of my daily practice. But I'll have a new answer to that, which is I've gotten really, really deep into tennis. And we joined a tennis club in this new little town that I moved to, California. And I've been playing a lot two, three times a week. And there's something really incredible about the game of tennis, because it requires such focus that when you're playing it, you're just completely in the moment, you have to be completely in the moment, or you will screw up and hit the ball out. So it forces a kind of focus. And that allows one to be connected. When I'm playing tennis, time doesn't really exist in the same way that exists in my regular life. My anxieties go away. And I know that's
这个问题。所以我平时会冥想，这是我日常生活的一部分。不过对于这个问题，我现在有了一个新的答案，那就是我最近真的、真的很迷网球。我们搬到的这个小镇上，也就是加州，我们加入了一个网球俱乐部。我一直在疯狂打网球，一周打两三次。网球这项运动有一种非常奇妙的特质，因为它需要极高的专注度，以至于当你打球时，你完全专注于当下，你必须完全专注于当下，否则你就会失误，把球打出界。所以它强迫你保持一种专注。而这让人能够产生连接感。当我在打网球时，时间仿佛不再以我现实生活中的那种方式存在了。我的焦虑感都消失了。我知道这
not a terribly profound one, but I have truly been felt feeling connected to the universe through tennis. I think that's great, because I think, for me, I have to get out of my head sometimes and get in my body. You know, when I get nervous or anxious about something, I stop everything, I put screens away, you know, I love tennis as well. But I like to just get in my body somehow, whether that's a hike, or just going on a long walk, just anything to just get back in my body and get out of my head. And I just love that rain. Do you remember working on my serve with me on the side of our soundstage? I had my racket, and I was telling you I was struggling with my serve. And so we went to the side of the
并不是一个多么深奥的回答，但我确实实实在在地通过网球感受到了与宇宙的连接。我觉得这很棒，因为我觉得对我来说，有时候我必须跳出自己的大脑，去感受自己的身体。你知道，当我因为某事感到紧张或焦虑时，我会停下一切，把屏幕都收起来，你知道的，我也很喜欢网球。但我喜欢通过某种方式去感受身体，不管是去徒步，还是去散个长步，只要能让我回到身体里、不再胡思乱想，什么都行。我真的太喜欢了，雷恩。你还记得在我们的摄影棚旁边帮我练习发球吗？我拿着网球拍，跟你说我在发球上遇到了瓶颈。然后我们走到
building where the hair and makeup trailers were, and you had you had me work on my toss, and then I would hit it on to the side of the building. And I did. And you told me my toss was horrible. It was like all about my toss. My toss wasn't high enough. Did you feel connected to the universe? As Rain told you, your toss was horrible, Angel. I felt frustrated, but connected. It's so funny. I, in that funny, how it must be old age, I have no memory of that. But that's, that's incredible. That's incredible. How was your serve these days? You know what? It's much better. It's much better. I do toss higher, but I also throw
靠近化妆间的那栋建筑旁边，你让我练习抛球，然后我把球朝着建筑物的墙壁上打。我照做了。你还告诉我我的抛球烂透了。全都是抛球的问题。我的抛球不够高。你当时感受到与宇宙的连接了吗？正如雷恩所说，你的抛球烂透了，安吉尔。我觉得很沮丧，但也有连接感。太搞笑了。我不觉得好笑吗，人老了是不是都这样，我完全不记得这事了。但这太不可思议了。你现在的发球怎么样？你知道吗？好多了。好多了。我抛球抛得更高了，而且我也以前所未有的方式全身心地扑上去击球。也许就像年过五十经历过去几年那些疯狂的事情一样，我以一种从未有过的方式扑向那个球。我的网球教练对我说：“安吉，你这一击挺有力量的。”他叫我安吉。不错。哇。太棒了。我身体压得很低，雷恩。我扭腰发力的动作很好。太奇妙了。
myself at it in a way I didn't before. Maybe it's like being 50 and having, you know, like the past few years of like just like craziness, I throw myself at that ball in a way I haven't before. And my tennis coach is like, oh, he got some power there, Angie. He calls me Angie. Nice. Wow. Fantastic. It's, it's, I'm like low to the ground, Rain. I've got a good torque. It's so weird. You guys, what a pleasure being on your show. And thanks for the deep dive. And God, what a, what an amazing pleasure it was watching Golden Ticket again. Really, that cold open to the KGB and the knock, knock jokes is, it was so good. That's such,
各位，能上你们的节目真是太荣幸了。谢谢你们的深入探讨。天哪，再次看到《金奖券》（Golden Ticket）这一集真是太让人享受了。真的，那个关于克格勃（KGB）和敲门笑话的冷场开场，实在是太精彩了。那是如此，
there's so many classic office moments throughout it. Rain, I have to ask, since you brought it up, how did you guys get through that cold open with slapping each other? I mean, because if you broke, you'd have to do it again. And obviously, you didn't want to have to keep slapping and getting slapped. But I mean, how'd you do it? People always ask like, how do you keep a straight face? In fact, I didn't keep a straight face. You didn't, Rain. You didn't because I watched the blue purse and you are one of the top breakers. I just laughed all the time, especially John and I, we would just make each other laugh. We could look at each other's eyes and know a laugh was coming. So I don't remember,
其中有那么多经典的办公室时刻。雷恩，我不得不问，既然你提到了，你们拍那个互相扇耳光的冷场开场时是怎么忍住不笑的？我的意思是，因为如果你笑场了，就得重拍。很显然，你肯定不想一直扇耳光和挨耳光。但我的意思是，你们是怎么做到的？大家总是问：你们是怎么保持严肃的表情的？事实上，我根本没保持住严肃。你没有，雷恩。你没有，因为我看过花絮，你绝对是最容易笑场的人之一。我一直在笑，特别是约翰和我，我们俩总是能把对方逗笑。我们只要看着对方的眼睛就知道要笑场了。所以我不记得了，
but I am certain that especially that little last section when John was like doing the KGB, that I'm sure I was crying with laughter and we had to cut, you know, at least a dozen times. I also, I mean, listen, the book end of this is that it starts with the KGB and it ends with the KGB in the tag and you going back and forth with the time when he's like, I'm busy and you're like, what's about 445? I was like, I know those guys were laughing. Yeah, I'm sure we can fit you in. Yes, 515. Rain, thank you so much for calling in and chatting with us. We love you. You are our most frequent guest on Office Ladies. That is your title. It belongs to you and we love you Rain and we love you. We love your heart. We love, you know, you have such a heart for service Rain
但我敢肯定，尤其是最后那小段，当约翰在模仿克格勃的时候，我肯定笑得眼泪都出来f了，我们至少重拍了十几次。还有，我的意思是，听着，这一集的首尾呼应是，它以克格勃开头，又以片尾彩蛋里的克格勃结束，你和他在时间上你来我往，他说“我很忙”，然后你说“差不多四点四十五怎么样？”当时我就想，我知道那俩家伙当时肯定在笑。对，我确信我们可以把你塞进行程里。好的，五点十五。雷恩，非常感谢你打电话来和我们聊天。我们爱你。你是《办公室女士》（Office Ladies）节目中最常来的嘉宾。这就是你的头衔。它属于你，我们爱你，雷恩，我们也爱你。我们爱你的心。我们知道，你有一颗乐于奉献的心，雷恩，
and I've always admired that about you and we're just excited for folks to hear a metaphysical milkshake and I love it because then it's kind of like, you know, you're in my bathroom with me. No, that's weird. Like I was listening as I got ready. But you know what I mean. You guys are the best. Congrats on the success of Office Ladies. I hope it launches an Oprah-esque empire for the two of you. Thank you. We'll receive that. We love you Rain. We'll talk to you soon. Take care. I want to come meet Alma. Yes, come over and meet the peacock. We will. All right. Bye. I just love that fella. I beyond love him. I love him. Rain, thank you so much for stopping by. And now lady, we got to get into this episode. Let's do it. You know,
我一直都很佩服你这一点，我们非常期待大家听到《形而上学的奶昔》，我太喜欢了，因为这就好像，你知道的，你就像是在我的浴室里陪着我一样。不，这太诡异了。就好像我一边准备出门一边在听一样。但你们懂我的意思。你们是最棒的。恭喜《办公室女士》大获成功。我希望它能为你们俩开启一个奥普拉式的商业帝国。谢谢。我们收下了。我们爱你，雷恩。我们回头聊。保重。我想去见阿尔玛（Alma）。好，过来见见那只孔雀。我们会去的。好的。再见。我太喜欢那家伙了。我简直爱死他了。雷恩，非常感谢你抽空做客。好了，女士们，我们得进入这一集的正题了。开始吧。你知道的，
we've talked a little bit about this cold open already, but we haven't really broken it down, so let's get into it. Pam is on the phone. She's trying to give someone like maybe a fax number. I want to point out at 10 seconds, Nick is still in office all day. In the, uh, in the note. In the post-it note. There's the same post-it note from last week. It's on the PINSTAR post-it paper. Nick in office all day. He's still there folks. So Michael's going to come over and he's messing with Pam. She's trying to give this phone number and he's like five or nine, three, two, like trying to mess her up. She hangs up and she's like, Michael, that makes us look so unprofessional. Yeah. Well, he can't wait. He's been there
我们已经讨论过这个冷场开场了，但还没有真正深入剖析，所以我们开始吧。帕姆在打电话。她正试图把某个号码，比如传真号码告诉别人。我想指出的是，在第 10 秒时，尼克整天都在办公室里。在那个，呃，在那个便签上。便签上有上周留下的同一张便签。它贴在 PINSTAR 的便签纸上。尼克整天都在办公室。各位，他还在那儿呢。所以迈克尔走过来捉弄帕姆。她正试图报这个电话号码，而他在旁边干扰：“五、九、三、二——”就像是在捣乱。她挂了电话，然后说：“迈克尔，这让我们显得很不专业。”是的。好吧，他已经等不及了。他一直待在那儿，
because he has a really good knock, knock joke for her. That's right. Knock, knock. Who's there? Buddha. Buddha who? Buddha this bread for me. And then he sits a stick of butter. It's been in his hand. It's not even in the wrapper. I know. I'll have you know, it was not scripted to be unwrapped, but on the day we just thought that would be really funny. And originally my line in the script, when I look at the butter and the everything on my desk, I was supposed to say, you're making a mess, but I changed it to there's butter on my desk. Yeah. And I thought that was like such a great little find in the moment when we were rehearsing. It's very Pam though. It's like people leave trash on your desk all the time things that you, it's just a statement. It's
因为他有一个非常棒的敲门笑话要讲给他听。没错了。敲敲门。是谁？佛陀。哪个佛陀？帮我“佛”（付）一下这块面包的钱（Put this bread for me）。然后他放了一根黄油条。这黄油一直抓在他手里。甚至连包装纸都没剥。我知道。我得告诉你们，剧本里可没写要剥开包装纸，但到了拍摄当天，我们临时觉得那样会非常搞笑。原本在剧本里，当我的台词是看着桌上的黄油和其他东西时，我本该说“你在搞得一团糟”，但我把它改成了“我桌上有黄油”。对。我觉得在排练时当场想出这一句真是太棒了。不过这真的很符合帕姆的风格。就像人们总是把垃圾留在你桌上，或者一些你觉得——这只是一种陈述。就像是
like resignation. It is. No, there's a better on my desk. Now there's butter on my desk. That's my day today. Well, Dwight is super excited about this knock, knock joke and he wants in on the fun. He's got a great one. Yeah. And he's like, Michael, please. And Michael doesn't want to hear it. He's like, please. And I just feel like we got to hear Dwight's knock, knock joke. Let's do it. Let's do it. No. Okay. Michael, please, please, please, please. Please let me. All right. Knock, knock. Who's there? KGB. KGB? What the hell was that? What are you doing? What are you doing? Hey, hey, stop it. So then they're just getting like the slapping fest and then Jim has to get in on it. Yep. Do we need to hear that one? No more knock, knock jokes. That's it. Ding dong. Who's there? KGB.
任命一样。确实。不，桌上有黄油。现在我桌上有黄油了。这就是我的日常生活。好吧，德怀特对这个敲门笑话兴奋极了，他想加入进来。他也有个很棒的笑话。是的。然后他说：“迈克尔，求你了。”而迈克尔不想听。他说：“求你了。”我觉得我们无论如何都得听听德怀特的敲门笑话。来吧。来吧。不。好吧。迈克尔，求你了，求你了，求你了，求你了。求你让我说。好吧。敲敲门。是谁？克格勃。克格勃？这他妈是什么鬼？你在干什么？你在干什么？嘿，嘿，住手。然后他们就开始了一场互扇耳机的戏，接着吉姆也得掺和进来。没错。我们需要听那个笑话吗？不准再讲敲门笑话了。就这样。叮咚。是谁？克格勃。
Dwight, get the door. I'm not answering the door. No way. It's the KGB. I'm not answering that. Yes, you're going to answer it. I'm not going to answer it. I'm not going to answer it. It's the KGB. The KGB will fit for no one. It's true. It's true. And there's the, it's true. And there it is. Well, now we're going to start the main plot of this episode. Michael arrives to work dressed as Willy Wonka. He's so excited. He points out the jelly beans. What are these? Pam's like jelly beans. She's like, no, they're extraordinary jelly beans. He's like so ready for his performance. And he shares that he's put this golden ticket 10% off in different boxes of paper
德怀特，去开门。我不去开门。没门。是克格勃。我不去开门。不，你得去开门。我不去开门。我不去开门。那是克格勃。克格勃才不会向任何人妥协。确实。确实。就是这样。好吧，现在我们要开始这一集的主剧情了。迈克尔打扮成威利·旺卡（Willy Wonka）来到公司。他兴奋极了。他指着果冻豆问：这是什么？帕姆说：果冻豆。他说：不，这是非凡的果冻豆。他已经完全进入状态准备表演了，并分享说他把这张能打 10% 折扣的金奖券塞进了不同的纸箱里，
and someone's going to get it and their day is going to be full of whimsy and excitement and fantasy. Here's what the golden ticket says. What? This whimsical promotion saves you 10% off your total order with Dunder Mifflin Scranton, Pennsylvania. That's what it says. This whimsical promotion. In the conference room, Michael is just like already taking credit for his great idea. It's such a great idea. He needs everyone to come in the conference room and talk about how we need more good ideas like this one. He says, and this is like something like people that do this crack me up. He goes, it might be the best idea ever in the history of ideas. You're like, okay, buddy.
总会有人拿到它，而他们的这一天将充满奇思妙想、兴奋和幻想。金奖券上是这么写的：什么？这项奇妙的促销活动可让您在宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿的邓德米夫林公司购买的总订单享受九折优惠。金奖券上就是这么写的。这项奇妙的促销活动。在会议室里，迈克尔已经在为自己的这个绝妙主意邀功了。这真是一个绝妙的主意。他需要每个人都来会议室，讨论我们如何需要更多像这样的好主意。他说——这种自我感觉良好的人总是让我忍俊不禁——他说：“这可能是创意史上最棒的创意。”你会觉得：好吧，老兄。
Here's what I don't understand. He's written on a board marketing greatness, Michael. I didn't get it. It was very amusing to me. Well, his job is to profiligate great ideas. I guess so. He really wants the group though to tell them their golden ticket idea. He knows his golden ticket. A golden ticket. Yeah. Jim's like, well, we could rent out our trucks. He's like, no, post it notes, right? Golden ticket. NASA, lots of golden ticket ideas there. Andy's going to say golden girls and a few other things. Let's start with the word golden. Let's start with golden grams. Look over his shoulder. Angela Martin, one minute, 59 seconds. Major eye roll at Andy.
我不明白的是：他在黑板上写下了“营销伟大，迈克尔”。我没看懂。这对我来说太搞笑了。好吧，他的工作就是大量炮制伟大的创意。我想是的吧。不过他真的很想让大家告诉他他们的金奖券创意。他知道自己的金奖券是什么。金奖券。对。吉姆说：好吧，我们可以把我们的卡车租出去。他说：不，便签纸，对吧？金奖券。美国宇航局，那里有很多金奖券的点子。安迪打算说“黄金女郎”（Golden Girls）和其他一些东西。让我们从“黄金”这个词开始。让我们从全麦饼干（Golden Grahams）开始。看他的肩膀。安吉拉·马丁（Angela Martin），在 1 分 59 秒时。对安迪大翻白眼。
Angela, eye roll. Yeah. She thinks Andy's an idiot, guys. She was only engaged to him just two seconds ago, but she's over it. Well, now we're going to move to the kitchen. Andy and Kevin are at the table. Pam and Jim are over by the counter. And Kevin really wants to ask out Lynn. And he's just getting a lot of advice from these guys, conflicting advice. I have two background catches that just delighted me. Oh. All right. Number one, these guys are both eating donuts. I noticed that. And I swear to God, those are the donuts we got every morning because Kevin's donut is my donut. The sprinkle's donut. Yes. And Andy had the powdered sugar. Okay. Background catch number two. I love it when our
安吉拉，翻白眼。对。在她眼里安迪就是个白痴，伙计们。就在两秒钟前她还跟他订过婚呢，不过她已经放下了。好吧，现在我们要转移到厨房。安迪和凯文在桌子旁。帕姆和吉姆在柜台边。凯文真的很想约琳（Lynn）出去，而他正从这几个人那里得到很多建议，甚至是矛盾的建议。我有两个背景细节让我感到惊喜。哦。好吧。第一点，这两个家伙都在吃甜甜圈。我注意到了。我向上帝发誓，那就是我们每天早晨买的甜甜圈，因为凯文的甜甜圈就是我的那款。撒了糖霜的甜甜圈。是的。安迪吃的是糖粉甜甜圈。好吧。背景细节之二。我太喜欢我们的
show does this, when it takes an object from a prior episode and pops it back into a new one. Ready? Four minutes. I think I saw it too. Kevin's coffee mug. Yep. Kevin's coffee mug is the same mug that Kelly gave to him at her customer survey party. You know, everyone's face in the big star. But what about Andy's mug? Andy's mug is the same one from Moroccan Christmas. And it was featured in a deleted scene I talked about when Jim and Pam decide to shop within the office for Christmas for each other because they're so broke. Jim goes up to Andy and asks him about his mug. And it's in the bloopers. It was also in the script. Two coffee mugs from two prior episodes. I love that. Well, later in this episode,
节目这一点了，当它把前一集里的一个道具重新拿出来用在一个新情节里时。准备好了吗？四分钟。我想我也看到了。凯文的咖啡杯。没错。凯文的咖啡杯就是凯利在她的客户调查派对上送给他的那个杯子。你知道的，上面印着大星星和每个人的脸。但安迪的杯子呢？安迪的杯子是《摩洛哥圣诞节》（Moroccan Christmas）里的那个。我在删减片段里提到过它，当时吉姆和帕姆因为太穷了，决定在办公室里互相为对方采购圣诞礼物。吉姆走到安迪身边问起他的杯子。这在NG花絮里出现过。它其实也写在剧本里。两个咖啡杯来自两个之前的剧集。我太喜欢这个了。好吧，在这集的晚些时候，
if you look at Oscar's desk, he's going to have his America's Got Talent mug too. Ah, love it. Well, this whole Kevin and Andy and Jim and Pam storyline was much bigger in the actual shooting draft. And there are a few deleted scenes and things I want to share. First of all, this is the scene that would have set up this whole storyline. It's at the beginning of the day, and they're getting in the elevator. Kevin, Jim and Pam, and who rushes in at the last minute because she works in the Scranton Business Park. But Lynn, can we hear it? Hold the rest, please. Hi, Kevin. Hey, Lynn. Did you get my message? Oh, yeah. I've been really busy. Oh, it's okay. Yeah, I'm probably going to be busy for the next 20 days or so.
如果你看奥斯卡的办公桌，他也会拿着他的《美国达人秀》（America's Got Talent）杯子。啊，太爱了。好吧，关于凯文、安迪、吉姆和帕姆的这条故事线在实际拍摄剧本中要庞大得多。这里有一些我想分享的删减片段和内容。首先，这是原本用来铺垫这条故事线的场景。那是上班刚开始的时候，他们在等电梯。凯文、吉姆和帕姆，还有谁因为在斯克兰顿商业园上班而急急忙忙冲了进来？是琳。我们来听听看。请帮我按一下电梯，谢谢。嗨，凯文。嗨，琳。你收到我的留言了吗？哦，对。我最近真的很忙。哦，没关系。对，我接下来大概二十天左右都会很忙。
So, yeah. Bye. You're going to be busy for the next 20 days or so. I thought you liked Lynn. I do like Lynn. That's what Andy told me to say. Uh-huh. Right? So Jim and Pam are learning that Andy has been giving Kevin some pretty bad advice. Yeah. He likes Lynn, but tells her, you know, he didn't return her messages, and he's going to be busy for 20 days. Wow. That's amazing. Jim and Pam can't let Andy do this to Kevin, so they start giving him advice, right? Just ask her out. And in the deleted scenes, you really get a sneak peek into where Andy's brain is at. You got to hear this talking head. I was raised to be a gentleman around women, but when your fiance is Satan, that doesn't work.
所以，呃，再见。你接下来二十天左右都会很忙？我还以为你喜欢琳呢。我是喜欢琳。那是安迪教我这么说的。哦——哦？对吧？所以吉姆和帕姆发现安迪一直在给凯文出一些非常糟糕的馊主意。对。他喜欢琳，却告诉她，你知道的，他没有回她的信息，而且他要忙上二十天。哇。太神奇了。吉姆和帕姆不能让安迪这样毁了凯文，所以他们开始给他出主意，对吧？直接约她出去呗。而在删减片段中，你真的能一窥安迪的内心世界。你必须听听这段独白。我接受的教育是在女性面前要做一个绅士，但当你的未婚妻是撒旦时，这招就行不通了。
So, I have some new ideas and new techniques, and I'm trying them out. Kevin Malone is my guinea pig. Aw, man, I wish that had stayed in. Doesn't that explain it all? It does. I mean, I think I was able to realize that the reason that Andy is being this way is because he's still reeling from his breakup with Angela, but that really would have been great. I know, because, I mean, I don't think Andy's a bad guy, but he's clearly hurt and acting out and using poor Kevin. Well, listen, Jim's going to get a phone call now. Guess what? What? His client, Tom, has found a golden ticket. Tom from Blue Cross of Pennsylvania. Our biggest client.
所以，我有一些新想法和新技巧，我正在尝试它们。凯文·马龙就是我的小白鼠。天哪，我真希望这段能保留下来。这难道不是解释了一切吗？确实。我的意思是，我觉得我能理解安迪为什么会这样，因为他依然没能从和安吉拉分手的阴影中走出来，但这段真的会很棒。我懂，因为，我的意思是，我不认为安迪是个坏人，但他显然受到了伤害，正在发泄情绪，并且在利用可怜的凯文。好吧，听着，吉姆现在要接个电话了。你猜怎么着？什么？他的客户汤姆发现了一张金奖券。宾夕法尼亚蓝十字（Blue Cross）的汤姆。我们最大的客户。
Uh-oh. Oscar, how much is that going to cost us? Michael wants to know. It's going to hurt a bit. Well, what about this? Guys, Tom found all five golden tickets. Holy moly. Did they say one per customer? Nope. Nope. Our biggest client just got 50% off their total order with us. I mean, this is a huge win. Talk about winning the golden ticket. He sure he won all the golden tickets. He won all of them. Um, this made me think, Jenna, have you ever won like a really big ticket item? I don't think so. I called my mom because I know my aunt, Ann, has won things. Like,
噢。奥斯卡，这会让我们损失多少钱？迈克尔想知道。这可要大出血了。那这个呢？伙计们，汤姆找到了全部五张金奖券。天哪。上面没写每位客户限一张吗？没有。没有。我们最大的客户刚刚拿到了全单五折优惠。我的意思是，这是一次巨大的胜利。这简直就是中了大奖。他确信他赢得了所有的金奖券吗？他赢得了全部。嗯，这让我想到，珍娜，你有没有赢过什么真正的大奖？好像没有。我给我妈打了电话，因为我知道我阿姨安（Ann）经常中奖。比如，
she signs up for, you know, raffles and things and she's won trips. Really? Yeah. She's super lucky. And I was like, Mom, doesn't Aunt Ann win a lot of things? And she said, well, you know, your dad won a very big ticket, Adam. What did your dad win? And I was like, Mom, what are you talking about? And she said, well, this was before you were born. And Jenna, this story just delighted me so much. One, because, you know, my dad's passed away. And so any new information, because, you know, you play every memory, you look at everything, but anything that you hear about someone you loved who's no longer with you, you just, oh, it's like this beautiful, wonderful thing.
她会报名参加各种抽奖活动，而且她赢过旅行。真的吗？对。她超级幸运。然后我就说：“妈，安姨是不是经常中奖？”她说：“噢，你知道的，你爸中过一个非常大的奖。”你爸中了什么？我当时就说：“妈，你在说什么呢？”她说：“哦，那是你出生之前的事了。”珍娜，这个故事让我太开心了。第一，因为，你知道的，我父亲已经去世了。所以任何新的信息——因为，你知道的，你会回忆每一个细节，审视一切——但任何关于你爱的人、而他已经不在了的消息，你都会觉得，哦，这就像是一件美丽而奇妙的事情。
So my mom said, Oh yeah, before you were born, we had just moved to Lafayette, Louisiana. And the school was having a fundraiser and they were raffling off a brand new pink station wagon. She said it had a cream white top and your dad went and donated some money and signed up and he won the car. Your dad won a pink station wagon. And she said, and it was a very good car and we drove it for a long time. Do any of your sisters remember this car? I was like, my sister, Billy said she remembers it. But I was like, Oh my goodness. And my mom's like, I know we have a picture somewhere. I said, Mom, please. And I have to see it. And she said, Oh, Ange, your dad was so tickled that he won that car. He was so excited. And she said, and it was
所以妈妈说：“哦，对，在你出生前，我们刚搬到路易斯安那州拉斐尔（Lafayette）。学校正在搞筹款活动，他们抽奖奖品是一辆崭新的粉色旅行车。”她说车顶是乳白色的，你爸爸去捐了点钱，填了表，结果他把车赢了。你爸爸赢得了一辆粉色旅行车？她说，那真是一辆极好的车，我们开了好长时间。你的姐姐们还记得这辆车吗？我说，我姐姐比利（Billy）说她记得。但我当时就想：“哦天哪。”我妈说：“我知道我们某处有一张照片。”我说：“妈，求你了。我一定要看看。”她说：“哦，安吉，你爸爸当时赢了那辆车可高兴了。他兴奋极了。”她说，那是一辆
a light pink with a cream top. And they drove it around for years. I love that story. I know. It made my day. You know, I have been pitching for years a documentary series that I call Little Winners. And it is all about people who have won not the lottery, but raffles. And they get something like this car or like a new recliner or like a trip, right? And how did it affect their life? Well, little winners. No one will buy it from me. No one wants to make it. I pitch it all the time. I will know when make Little Winners. I love Little Winners. We could do it as a podcast and have the winner on. They could tell us all about it. Here's the thing. You know, I like to think about my parents. They were young parents. They had three young girls
浅粉色搭配乳白色车顶的车。他们开了好多年。我太喜欢这个故事了。我懂。这让我一整天心情都很好。你知道的，我多年来一直向人推销一个我称之为《小小赢家》（Little Winners）的纪录片系列。它讲的全都是那些中过奖的人——不是指中彩票，而是中抽奖——他们赢得了像这辆车、一把新躺椅或者一次旅行这样的奖品，对吧？这会对他们的生活产生什么影响？好吧，《小小赢家》，没人肯买我的版权。没人想拍。我一直在推销它。总有一天我要把《小小赢家》拍出来。我太喜欢《小小赢家》了。我们可以把它做成一个播客，把得奖者请来。他们可以跟我们讲讲这一切。事情是这样的。你知道的，我喜欢想象我的父母。他们当时是年轻的父母，有三个年幼的女儿，
at this time and what that car meant to them. And then I also think about the car dealer there in Lafayette, Louisiana and how the school, probably the superintendent was buddies with the guy at the dealership and was like, what do you got that we can raffle off? And he's like, well, that pink station wagon, no one wants it. We can't sell it. It's a write off. Yeah, I'll give it to you. Amazing. So Michael is spiraling out, though, because he's realizing Blue Cross from Pennsylvania getting this many golden tickets. He's going to get fired. And Jim is upset too, because that's his commission. Oh, right. Right. So Michael is going to storm down to the warehouse. I love the beginning of the scene. This scene is brilliant. He goes barreling in going, hey,
那个车对他们来说意味着什么。然后我还会去想路易斯安那州拉斐尔的那家汽车经销商，以及学校——可能校长跟那个经销商的家伙是铁哥们儿，然后校长问：“你这儿有什么可以拿来抽奖的？”对方说：“哦，那辆粉色旅行车，没人想要。我们卖不出去。这可以算作冲销账目。行，我送给你了。”太神奇了。不过迈克尔现在整个人要崩溃了，因为他意识到宾夕法尼亚的蓝十字拿到了这么多金奖券。他要被解雇了。而且吉姆也很沮丧，因为那可是他的佣金。哦，对。对。所以迈克尔要气势汹汹地冲去仓库。我太喜欢这个场景的开头了。这个场景简直绝了。他大步流星地冲进去说：“嘿，嘿，嘿，你个白痴”——对达里尔（Daryl）说的。而达里尔说：“从头来过。”太棒了。当时我就想：我要把这句保留下来。
hey, hey, you idiot to Daryl. And Daryl says, start over. So good. I was like, I'm keeping that. I am keeping that. The next time one of the kids has a moment where they're sassing me, I'm going to be like, start over. Exactly. And then Michael comes back with sir. That was all in the script. I looked that up. So did I. So did I. Michael's like, Daryl, how could this happen? How could this happen? And he says, I put three pallets on the truck for Blue Cross every week. Where were you putting the boxes? Were they near each other? And Michael's like, I need to ask you something. I need you to be honest with me. What is a pallet? So good. So good. David Wallace is not happy. He calls. Pam takes the call.
我要把这句留着。下次孩子们再跟我顶嘴时，我就对他们说：“从头来过。”没错。然后迈克尔改口叫了声“先生”。剧本里就是这么写的。我特意查过了。我也是。我也是。迈克尔说：“达里尔，这怎么可能发生？这怎么可能发生？”达里尔说：“我每周给蓝十字在卡车上装三个托盘的货。你把箱子都摆在哪儿了？它们靠得很近吗？”而迈克尔却说：“我得问你个事。我需要你对我说实话。什么是托盘？”太棒了。太棒了。大卫·华莱士（David Wallace）很不高兴。他打电话来了。帕姆接了电话。
But Michael is sort of sneaking out of his office. He's taken off his Willy Wonka outfit. Yeah, he's getting rid of the evidence. Yes. He's like, Duna, I am not here. I am not here. So Pam has to say that he's at a civil rights rally at the Lincoln Memorial, which I want to point out is in Washington. Yeah. He's gone to Washington DC, I guess. In the same day, he's going to go to a civil rights movement in Washington DC and get a colonoscopy in Scranton. Exactly. Well, Michael tosses his Willy Wonka costume into a dumpster. He's now wearing a Pioneer's football shirt. And I had to look this up. This is a minor league football team from Wilkesbury Scranton that played in the AF2 and they had a really strong
但迈克尔正鬼鬼祟祟地溜出他的办公室。他已经脱掉了威利·旺卡的戏服。是的，他在销毁证据。没错。他说：“德纳（Duna），我不在。我不在。”所以帕姆不得不说他在林肯纪念堂参加民权集会——我想指出的是，那个纪念堂在华盛顿。对。我想他大概是去华盛顿特区了吧。在同一天里，他既要去华盛顿特区参加民权运动，又要在斯克兰顿做肠镜检查。没错。好吧，迈克尔把他的威利·旺卡戏服扔进了一个垃圾桶。他现在穿着一件“先锋队”（Pioneer）橄榄球队的球衣。我特意查了一下。这是一支来自威尔克斯巴里·斯克兰顿（Wilkes-Barre Scranton）的小联盟橄榄球队，参加了 AF2 联赛，在 2009 年我们拍摄这一集时，他们度过了非常强劲的
season in 2009 when we shot this episode. It's kind of like perfect that he's wearing this shirt because they only ended up losing two of their games that year. They made it to the playoffs, then they made it all the way to the Arena Cup, which is like the Super Bowl of AF2 football. They ended up losing, but it was like a great, great season for them. They were kind of on a roll. Their previous season had been good as well. I love it. I love every time we have every single time these local references on the show in ways that don't even get mentioned. Right. We never even mentioned this shirt, but there it is just creating specificity. I love it. Michael's going to make an announcement everyone to the conference room. He's
一个赛季。他穿着这件球衣简直再合适不过了，因为他们那一年整个赛季只输了两场比赛。他们打进了季后赛，然后一路杀入了竞技杯（Arena Cup），这就好比是 AF2 橄榄球的超级碗。他们最后虽然输了，但这可以说是他们非常、非常棒的一个赛季。他们当时正处于连胜的势头中。他们上一个赛季的表现也很不错。我太喜欢了。我真的超爱每一次——每一次节目中出现这些本地彩蛋，甚至都不用明说。对。我们甚至从来没有提起过这件球衣，但它就穿在那儿，凭空增添了真实感。我太喜欢了。迈克尔要向大家宣布一件事：所有人来会议室。他
a lot of announcements in this episode, a lot of announcements. He's really, I think, just trying to find a way out. He says he has a big net where he takes all of their subconscious ideas and tries to turn them into something. And Michael's like, they're not going to fire us. We're fine. And Oscar's like, what do you call shutting down a branch? And then Michael says, someone needs to come up with a golden ticket idea to get them out of this mess. And Pam says, do you mean an idea that blows up in our faces later? That kind of idea? That's some PAM sass. That is some PAM sass. So while Michael's up at the top of the conference room, he's wearing a suit jacket. And I'm thinking, where did that come from? Because the last time
在这一集里宣布了好多事，发布了好多公告。我猜他真的只是在想方设法找退路。他说他有一个大网，能把他们所有人的潜意识想法都收集起来并试图把它们变成现实。而迈克尔说：“他们不会开除我们的。我们没事。”奥斯卡却说：“那你怎么管关闭分公司叫？”接着迈克尔说，必须有人想出一个金奖券的主意来把他们从这个烂摊子里救出来。帕姆说：“你是说那种后来在咱们脸上炸开的主意吗？那种主意吗？”这可是帕姆式的毒舌。这绝对是帕姆式的毒舌。所以当迈克尔站在会议室前面时，他穿着一件西装外套。我在想：这外套是从哪儿冒出来的？因为我们上次看到他时，他还在垃圾桶旁穿着先锋队的橄榄球队服呢。我查过了。那是安迪的外套。他穿着安迪的外套。
we saw him, he was at the dumpster in his Pioneer's football shirt. I looked it up. It's Andy's jacket. He's wearing Andy's jacket. And there was a bit at the top of this scene that got cut where as they're entering the room, Michael says, Andy, give me your jacket. You can do something for me. I want your jacket. So that is why he's now wearing this odd jacket over his football shirt. Well, he's got to still look like the boss. The phone's going to ring now. Not good. It's David Wallace. Pam says Michael's having a colonoscopy. I'm not sure that David Wallace believes that. You think? Because he was just in Washington. Michael gets on the phone with him and literally is reading off the procedure of how you give a colonoscopy
在这个场景的开头原本有一段被剪掉的戏：当他们走进房间时，迈克尔说：“安迪，把你的外套脱给我。你能帮我个忙。我要你的外套。”所以这就是为什么他现在会在足球衫外面套着这件奇怪的外套。好吧，他毕竟还得装成老板的样子。电话现在要响了。不妙。是大卫·华莱士打来的。帕姆说迈克尔正在做肠镜检查。我不确定大卫·华莱士会信这个。你觉得呢？因为他刚才还在华盛顿呢。迈克尔接起他的电话，居然直接从电脑上念起了做肠镜检查的操作流程。这真是太绝了。但现在情况已经很明朗了。大卫·华莱士说，公司要损失一大笔钱。你怎么能让这种事发生？这是谁的主意？必须有人为这个糟糕的主意付出代价。迈克尔告诉大卫·华莱士那是德怀特的主意。真是太阴险了。我懂。哦，迈克尔。
off his computer. It's pretty amazing. But now it is clear. David Wallace says, the company is going to lose a lot of money. How did you let this happen? Whose idea was it? Someone's got to pay for this terrible idea. Michael tells David Wallace it was Dwight. Just so devious. I know. Oh, Michael. It's like David Wallace is just naming people and he says, was it Dwight? And Michael's like, yes. Well, now Michael has got to convince Dwight to take the fall for him. And so he's going to get out his diary and he's going to say Dwight, I wrote it down that it was your idea. He tries to convince Dwight that Dwight is remembering wrong. What happened this morning? Now Dwight runs to get his diary. It's like the dueling
就好像大卫·华莱士在挨个点名一样，然后他说：“是德怀特吗？”迈克尔回答：“是的。”好吧，现在迈克尔必须说服德怀特替他背黑锅。于是他掏出自己的日记本，说：“德怀特，我当时记下来了，这就是你的主意。”他试图说服德怀特是德怀特自己记错了。今天早上到底发生了什么？现在德怀特跑去拿他的日记本。这就像是两本对质的日记，你来我往。迈克尔意识到用日记本这招根本占不到便宜，于是他说：“你想跟我一起去吃午饭吗？就我们俩。”德怀特说：“我全心全意……”这个场景在剧本里还有后续，珍娜。所以在德怀特说了“我全心全意”之后，他接着说：“但我已经吃过午饭了。”迈克尔说：“现在才早上11点。”德怀特说：“作为一个农民，我早上4点半吃早饭。到10点我就饿得想吃午饭了。如果你等上三个小时，我们或许可以吃晚饭。”迈克尔说：“不，不，不。要不我们做点你喜欢别的什么事？”珍娜，你有没有注意到镜头里根本没有他们在餐厅的场景？他们本该去吃午饭的，对吧？因为在正片里，迈克尔说的是“去吃午饭吧”。我们并不知道德怀特已经吃过了。所有这些都被剪掉了，对吧？然后他们剩下的场景就都变成了在路边散步。
diaries where they're going back and forth. Michael realizes he's not making any headway with this whole diary business. So he says, would you like to go out to lunch with me? Just the two of us. And Dwight says, with all my heart, this scene continues in the script, Jenna. So after Dwight says with all my heart, he says, but I already ate lunch. And Michael says, it's 11 a.m. Dwight says, as a farmer, I eat breakfast at 4.30. At 10, I'm famished for lunch. If you wait three hours, we can have supper, maybe. Michael says, no, no, no. How about we do something else you like? Jenna, did you notice there are no scenes of them at the restaurant? They're supposedly going to have lunch, right? Because in the episode, Michael says, go have
好吧，这里有一个被删掉的场景，我真的超级喜欢。在德怀特想做的一切事情里面，你猜他最喜欢做什么？去散步？哦，女士，才不是呢。他喜欢溜达。你还在进行你喜欢的那种溜达吗？一周三次。好吧，那我们一起去溜达溜达吧。我以为你说我的溜达很傻呢。不，那是因为你不能管那叫走路。你真的想溜达？对。你想强力溜达还是普通溜达？你说了算。强力溜达。好吧。你涂防晒霜了吗？涂了。防晒指数多少？1。那跟水有什么区别。
lunch. We don't know that Dwight's already eaten. All of that's been cut out, right? And then the remainder of their scenes, they're on the side of the road. They're taking a walk. Well, here is a scene that was in the deleted scenes that I just love so much. Of all the things that Dwight would want to do, guess what he loves to do? Go for walks? Oh, lady, no. He likes a stroll. Are you still taking those strolls that you like to take? Thrice weekly. Okay, let's go take a stroll together. I thought you said my strolls were silly. No, just because you can't call them walks. You really want a stroll? Yes. You want a power stroll or just a regular stroll? You call it. Power stroll. Okay. You wearing sunblock? Yes. What SPF? One. That's like water.
我去拿我的防晒乳。好吧。他太喜欢溜达了。显然，他和迈克尔之间把这叫作“溜达”还是“走路”已经成了一个梗。然后还有另一个场景，他们走到大厅里，汉克（Hank）也在那儿，德怀特正往迈克尔脸上一抹防晒霜，汉克抬头面无表情地说：“你总算找到人陪你溜达了。”德怀特说：“对啊。”汉克说：“不错。”这太棒了，因为我们收到了大量邮件，观众们都在指出德怀特在走路（也就是和迈克尔一起溜达）时脚上穿的鞋子。无数人都在问：“为什么德怀特穿着一双非常白、非常不符合德怀特风格的运动鞋？这鞋是从哪儿来的？”我在剧本里查了一下，上面写着：迈克尔和德怀特在走路。德怀特穿着运动鞋，双手背在身后走路。这就像是个剧本备注，但我敢肯定，这一切都是基于这样一个背景故事：德怀特每周要溜达三次。他自带防晒霜。他有自己的鞋子。他可能还有一个专门带去上班的小包。显然，汉克很清楚德怀特有多喜欢溜达，也知道他一直在寻找一个溜达搭子。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。你知道的，这把我逗乐了。
I'll grab my tube. Okay. He loves a stroll. Clearly, it's like a whole thing with him and Michael about calling it a stroll or a walk. Then there's another scene where they're down in the lobby and Hank is there and Dwight is putting sunscreen on Michael's face and Hank looks up and deadpan says, you found somebody to go on a stroll. And Dwight goes, I did. And Hank goes, nice. This is amazing because we got a ton of mail because people were pointing out Dwight's shoes in the scene when he is walking, aka strolling with Michael. Tons of people said, why does Dwight have on very white, very non Dwight trainers? Like, where did these come from? And I looked in the script and it says Michael and Dwight are walking. Dwight is wearing sneakers
好吧，这次溜达并没能说服德怀特。德怀特说：“我才不会为你两肋插刀呢。门都没有。”他以前干过这事。他曾经为迈克尔两肋插刀，结果一点也不愉快。确实不愉快。迈克尔对德怀特发表了一番长篇大论。他说：“听着，你为什么还想待在这儿？你整天被关在里面。你连安吉拉都不约会了。你可有一整座农场呢。”对。然后他说：“另一方面，如果没有了邓德米夫林，我将迷失方向。”德怀特说：“那舒拉拉（Shulala）呢，迈克尔？”这绝对是敏迪·卡灵（Mindy Kaling）的手笔。这上面深深打上了敏迪·卡灵的烙印。接着迈克尔有一段独白，他说他想开一家高档男鞋店，名字就叫“舒拉拉”。那是一家专门卖男士正装鞋的店，只为男人一生中的特殊时刻准备，比如结婚的那天，或者妻子生孩子的那天，又或者只是为了在家里闲逛时穿。对。好吧，我们收到了来自凯拉·G（Kayla G）的一封邮件，她说：“我只想让你们女士们知道，迈克尔似乎已经在不列颠哥伦比亚省的纳尔逊（Nelson）把‘舒拉拉’开业运营了。”哦。我特意去查了一下，果不其然，那里真的有一家叫“舒拉拉”的店。
and walks with his hands clasped behind his back. That was like a script note, but I'm sure it was all based on this backstory that Dwight strolls three times a week. He's got his sunblock. He's got his shoes. He probably has a little bag he takes to work. Clearly, Hank knows how much Dwight loves a stroll and how he's been looking for a stroll, buddy. I love it. I love it. You know, it tickled me. Well, this stroll is not going to convince Dwight. Dwight says, I am not going to fall on my sword for you. It's not going to happen. He's done it before. He's fallen on his sword and it wasn't pleasant. It wasn't. Michael makes a pretty big speech to Dwight. He's like, listen, why would you want to stay here? You're cooped up. You're not even dating Angela anymore. You have
双手扣在背后散步。这就像是一个剧本提示，但我敢肯定这完全是基于德怀特一周散步三次的背景故事。他涂了防晒霜。他穿着鞋子。他可能还有一个带去上班的小包。很明显，汉克知道德怀特有多喜欢散步，也知道他一直在找一个散步的搭子。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。你知道，这把我逗乐了。好吧，这次散步并不能说服德怀特。德怀特说，我不会为你当替罪羊的。这不可能发生。他以前做过。他当过替罪羊，那滋味可不好受。确实不好受。迈克尔对德怀特发表了一番慷慨激昂的演讲。他说，听着，你为什么想留在这里？你被关在这里。你甚至都不和安吉拉约会了。你有
a whole farm. Yeah. And he says, you know, on the other hand, I would be lost without Dunder Mifflin. And Dwight says, what about Shulala, Michael? This is a Mindy Kaling thing, for sure. This has Mindy Kaling written all over it. And then Michael has a talking head where he says, I have an idea for a fancy men's shoe store called Shulala. And it's just men's shoes for the special occasions in a man's life, like the day that you get married or the day your wife has a baby or just for lounging around the house. Yeah. Well, we got some mail from Kayla G who said, I just want to let you ladies know that Michael seems to have gotten Shulala up and running in Nelson, British Columbia. Oh. And I looked it up and sure enough, there is a Shulala.
整整一个农场。是的。他说，你知道，另一方面，如果离开邓德米夫林，我会迷失方向的。德怀特说，那“舒拉拉”呢，迈克尔？这绝对是敏迪·卡灵的风格。这上面到处都是敏迪·卡灵的印记。然后迈克尔有一个单采镜头，他说，我有一个开一家名为“舒拉拉”的高档男鞋店的想法。这里只卖男人一生中特殊场合穿的男鞋，比如你结婚的那天，或者你妻子生孩子的那天，或者只是为了在家里闲逛。是的。好吧，我们收到了一封来自凯拉·G的邮件，她说，我只是想让两位女士知道，迈克尔似乎已经在不列颠哥伦比亚省纳尔逊市把“舒拉拉”开起来并正常营业了。哦。我查了一下，果真有一家“舒拉拉”。
According to their website, they are a boutique shoe store offering exquisite leather footwear and handbags from all over the world. They are a family run business that has been around since 1983. Hmm. Well, I want you guys to know that there is a Shulala in Lafayette, Louisiana. I saw that too. My town where I was born. Lafayette. And you know what? I love the slogan for their shoe store. If you go on their website, it's a clothing boutique and shoes. But their slogan is, life is short by the damn shoes. That is amazing. So there are two Shulalas, Michael, but none of them seem to sell men's shoes. Oh, well, I would love nothing more for Michael to have Shulala. Well, we have a great reverse talking head. Yes, I noticed. So Dwight is in
根据他们的网站，这是一家精品鞋店，提供来自世界各地的精美皮革鞋履和手袋。这是一家家族企业，自1983年以来一直存在。嗯。好吧，我想让大家知道，在路易斯安那州拉斐特有一家舒拉拉。我也看到了。我出生的那个小镇。拉斐特。你知道吗？我喜欢他们鞋店的标语。如果你去他们的网站，它是一个服装精品店和鞋店。但他们的标语是，人生苦短，买该死的鞋。这太棒了。所以有两个舒拉拉，迈克尔，但似乎没有一个卖男鞋。哦，好吧，我最希望迈克尔能拥有舒拉拉。好吧，我们有一个很棒的反向访谈。是的，我注意到了。所以德怀特在
Michael's chair and you pull back to reveal Michael perched behind him. Basically in this talking head, Michael's like, he's going to do it for me. He's going to do it. He's going to take the fall. And Dwight's like, no, I haven't decided. Well, folks in the office are starting to catch on. They get it. They know what Michael's doing. He wants Dwight to take the fall and they start gossiping about it. There's a scene in the kitchen, you guys, that was deleted where Meredith, Kelly, and Angela, and Oscar are all being real chatty. And Michael walks in and overhears a bit and he's spying on them from the bathroom. Let's hear it. Ladies, really? I hope Dwight gets fired and we get a hot new guy to replace them. Seriously. What if it's a hot
迈克尔的椅子上，镜头拉回，展现出迈克尔盘踞在他身后。基本上在这个访谈中，迈克尔的意思是，他要替我顶罪。他要这么做。他要当替罪羊。而德怀特则说，不，我还没决定。好吧，办公室里的人开始察觉了。他们懂了。他们知道迈克尔在做什么。他想让德怀特顶罪，于是他们开始八卦。厨房里有一个场景，你们知道的，被删掉了，里面梅雷迪思、凯莉、安吉拉和奥斯卡都在热烈地聊天。迈克尔走进来，偷听了一点，他在洗手间里偷窥他们。我们听听看。女士们，真的吗？我希望德怀特被解雇，然后我们换个性感的新帅哥来代替他们。真的吗。如果是个性感
new girl? Oh my God, I had not thought of that. I think it's horrible what Michael is doing. Really? I mean, this is unacceptable. Hey, did you notice that our bathroom is right next to our kitchen? How's that up to code? I don't know. This is not fair. What are you doing to Dwight? Of course you think that. You used to bone the guy. I think men bone women. I hate that I'm correcting that. All I'm saying is that Dwight can't take the blame for this. It has to land on Michael. It's time for a reckoning. That's true. Okay, these are the kind of slice of life. Slice of life. Slice of life. You brought it back. These are the kind of slice of life office moments that I love so much. Just the scuttle butt. There's so much going on. Just the gossip and the
的新女孩呢？哦天哪，我没想过那个。我觉得迈克尔的做法太可怕了。真的吗？我的意思是，这太让人不能接受了。嘿，你有没有注意到我们的洗手间就在厨房旁边？这怎么符合规范的？我不知道。这太不公平了。你对德怀特做什么？你当然会这么想。你以前跟那家伙上过床。我认为男人跟女人上床。我讨厌我正在纠正这个。我只想说，德怀特不能为此背锅。这必须落在迈克尔头上。是时候算账了。没错。好吧，这些就是那种生活切片。生活切片。生活切片。你把它找回来了。这就是我非常喜欢的办公室生活切片时刻。就是那些闲话。有太多事情在发生了。只有八卦和
opinions. Uh-huh. You know, I loved this scene and Michael overhears it, you guys. And there's a whole scene where Michael confronts everyone and he really lets them have it. He goes barging into the bullpen and he's like, hey, everyone, I need to make an announcement. And Jim is like, this is a new record. And Michael goes, that's because I have a lot to say today. James. Uh-huh. He's ticked off. And then he goes around the room and he's like, yells to the room, have you wondered what it would be like if I was fired and everyone super happy raises their hand? And Michael's like, damn it. I didn't ask for a show of hands. If I get fired and corporate brings in new leadership, you have no idea who might come. And then he starts singling people out. He says,
观点。嗯哼。你知道，我喜欢这个场景，迈克尔偷听了，伙计们。还有一个完整的场景，迈克尔与每个人对质，他真的狠狠地教训了他们。他闯进办公区，就像，嘿，各位，我需要宣布一件事。吉姆就说，这刷新了新纪录。迈克尔说，那是因为我今天有很多话要说。詹姆斯。嗯哼。他气炸了。然后他绕着房间走，大声向全场喊道，你们有没有想过如果我被解雇了会是什么样，然后所有人都超级高兴地举起了手。迈克尔就像，该死。我没要求举手。如果我被解雇了，总公司带来新的领导层，你们根本不知道谁会来。然后他开始点名道姓，他说，
you have no idea how bad it could get. Maybe it would be someone who knows that we don't actually need three accountants. I remember shooting this scene now. Yes. It's in the deleted scenes. Then he looks right at Jim and Pam and he says, or let's couples work together without sending them to different branches. And then he has this moment and made me laugh. He goes, so you didn't think about that, huh? So let's just bite our tongues instead of saying mean things about me when I pretend to be pooping in the bathroom. Okay. But it was a long speech and he really just lets them all have it. I love this episode so much. I think Steve Carell just is brilliant in this episode. He's playing so many different things. We already talked about
你们根本不知道事情会变得多糟。也许会来一个知道我们其实根本不需要三个会计的人。我记起拍摄这个场景了。是的。它在删除片段里。然后他直盯着吉姆和帕姆说，或者让情侣们一起工作而不把他们调到不同的分部。然后他有了这个时刻，让我笑出来。他说，所以你们没想过这个，对吧？所以让我们咬紧牙关，而不是在我假装在洗手间大便时说我的坏话。好吧。但这是一场冗长的演讲，他真的狠狠地教训了他们所有人。我太喜欢这一集了。我觉得史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在这集里简直太才华横溢了。他表现了太多不同的东西。我们已经讨论过
this with Rain, but I just absolutely love the Michael Dwight dynamic. I really loved this one. I did too. This was like one of those sleeper ones that we hadn't seen in forever and we're like, oh my gosh, golden ticket. I agree. Golden ticket is a golden ticket. Well, now David Wallace is going to show up. He drove from New York, you guys. Yeah. David Wallace arrives at the office, right? This is a serious thing. Yeah. He goes into Michael's office with Dwight. You could hear a pin drop. And he turns to Dwight and he says, Dwight, I owe you an apology. Blue Cross was so excited about the golden ticket promotion that they have made Dunder Mifflin their exclusive provider for all office supplies. Huge. This is huge. And he puts his
这个，和雷恩一起，但我绝对太喜欢迈克尔和德怀特的动态了。我真的很喜欢这一集。我也是。这就像是我们好久没见的那种慢热集，然后我们就想，哦天哪，金奖券。我同意。金奖券就是金奖券。好吧，现在大卫·华莱士要出现了。他从纽约开车来的，伙计们。是的。大卫·华莱士到达了办公室，对吧？这是一件严肃的事。是的。他带着德怀特走进迈克尔的办公室。现场鸦雀无声。他转向德怀特说，德怀特，我欠你一个道歉。蓝十字对金奖券促销活动非常兴奋，他们已经将邓德米夫林定为所有办公用品的独家供应商。太重大了。这太重大了。然后他伸出
hand out to shake Dwight's hand. Michael is about to split in half. He's looking at Dwight like, you better let him know it was my idea. And Dwight shakes his hand and says, thank you, David. And now all the power has been flipped. Amazing, amazing writing. They go out into the bullpen. Wallace tells everybody. Dwight gets this victory lap. Pam hugs him. I loved doing that. I loved it. And then Creed's like, way to go, kid. I don't. Creed is like, sure, it was Dwight. Dwight, Jim is giving Dwight credit and they are all watching Michael squirm. And then David's like, you know what, Dwight? You need to talk to the marketing guys in New York. Incorporate. We want to hear more of your ideas. More of your brilliance. Pam, can you set up that
手去和德怀特握手。迈克尔快要裂成两半了。他看着德怀特，仿佛在说，你最好让他知道那是我的主意。德怀特握了握他的手说，谢谢你，大卫。现在所有的权力都逆转了。惊人，惊人的编剧。他们走到办公区。华莱士告诉了所有人。德怀特赢得了胜利的巡游。帕姆拥抱了他。我喜欢那样。我喜欢。然后克里德说，干得好，孩子。我不。克里德就像，当然，那是德怀特。德怀特，吉姆在给德怀特记功，他们都在看着迈克尔坐立不安。然后大卫说，你知道吗，德怀特？你需要和纽约的营销人员谈谈。总公司。我们想听到你的更多点子。更多你的才华。帕姆，你能安排那个
call? And Michael's like, I could be in there and he's like, no, no, no, no, no, no. You got things to do. Come on, Dwight. Being in that conference room for that phone call was a delight. This was one of my favorite things to do. We've talked about this. I loved taking notes during these comedic scenes. And, you know, pretty soon, Pam isn't going to be the receptionist anymore. I know. And this was the part of the job that I missed the most. Getting to be in these ridiculous situations with Michael. Being the note taker because they're on the phone and Dwight is just saying ridiculous stuff. And of course, Michael Burson. Right. Because it's really clear that Dwight doesn't know anything
通话吗？迈克尔就说，我可以进去，而他就像，不，不，不，不，不，不。你有很多事要做。来吧，德怀特。为了那个电话会议坐在会议室里真是一种享受。这是我最喜欢做的事情之一。我们讨论过这个。我喜欢在这些喜剧场景中做笔记。而且，你知道，很快，帕姆就不是前台了。我知道。这是工作中我最怀念的部分。能和迈克尔一起经历这些荒谬的情况。当笔记员，因为他们在打电话，而德怀特一直在说荒谬的话。当然，迈克尔在插嘴。对。因为很显然德怀特根本不知道
about Willy Wonka. No. Then call back. Call back to a deleted scene, but that we love the toilet, buddy. That's right. This is a deleted scene from Job Fair. Remember, Michael comes out of the bathroom flustered because all the contents of his pockets fell into the toilet. Yes. And then he threw his cell phone in the toilet out of anger. Yes. And he says then that he had this brilliant idea about this mesh toilet guard cover. Now, Jenna, in the episode, Michael calls it the toilet buddy. But in the shooting draft, it was called the toilet guard. And I think in the moment, Steve called it toilet buddy because then he corrects himself as Michael. He goes previously known as the toilet guard. Yes. So I think that's just Steve staying in the moment, but catching that
关于威利·旺卡的任何事。不。然后回电。回溯到一个被删减但我们很喜欢的场景，马桶好伙伴。没错了。这是《招聘会》的一个删除片段。还记得吗，迈克尔慌乱地从洗手间出来，因为他口袋里的所有东西都掉进了马桶里。是的。然后他一气之下把手机扔进了马桶。是的。然后他说他有了一个关于这种网状马桶防护罩的绝妙点子。现在，詹娜，在这一集中，迈克尔称它为马桶好伙伴。但在拍摄剧本中，它被称为马桶防护罩。我猜当时史蒂夫叫它马桶好伙伴是因为他作为迈克尔随后纠正了自己。他说以前被称为马桶防护罩。是的。所以我觉得那只是史蒂夫保持在情境中，但意识到
he had flubbed a line. And then Dwight mentions his idea called horse boat, which I love horse boat. You can go from riding to just being on the water. And then Michael hits back with toilet sponge. I don't know what that was. It's more absorbent. The toilet sponge. It's more absorbent. So it's a toilet. That's a sponge. No, I think it's a sponge for your bum. Oh, I don't know. It doesn't say. We're not sure. He says it's more absorbent. That's what he says. Now, lady, in this back and forth, this brought up a product that my friend Stacy and I invented in high school that we thought we were convinced was our ticket to being millionaires. What? It's called the tan baster. You know that thing that you wash your dishes with that you fill up with dish soap and it has
他台词说错了。然后德怀特提到了他的点子叫马船，我太喜欢马船了。你可以从骑马直接变成在水上。然后迈克尔回击了马桶海绵。我不知道那是什么。它吸收性更好。马桶海绵。它吸收性更好。所以它是一个马桶。那是一个海绵。不，我觉得那是给你屁股用的海绵。哦，我不知道。上面没说。我们不确定。他说它吸水性更好。他是这么说的。现在，女士，在这个你来我往中，这勾起了一个产品，我和我的朋友斯黛西在高中时发明的，我们当时深信这是我们成为百万富翁的门票。什么？它叫美黑涂抹刷。你知道那种洗碗时用的、里面装满洗洁精并且有
little sponge at the end. Yes. The tan baster is very similar, Angela. It has a little sponge on the end, but it's filled with sunblock and you just baste it on yourself and your hands stay clean. The tan baster. Or you could get spray. Well, spray wasn't around yet, Angela. It hadn't been invented yet. You see now we can go nowhere with the tan baster, but at the time it could have been. There was a need and clearly the spray has filled the need, but. And the stick. I love me a sunscreen stick. Yeah, and I get it. There's a lot of solutions today, but I'm taking you back to the 1990s when none of these things existed except for goopy sunblock and we were solving a problem. Also, we had the whole like television commercial, the whole infomercial in our head
一个小海绵在顶端的的东西吗？是的。美黑涂抹刷非常相似，安吉拉。它顶端有一个小海绵，但里面装满了防晒霜，你只需把它涂在自己身上，你的手就能保持干净。美黑涂抹刷。或者你可以买喷雾。好吧，当时还没有喷雾呢，安吉拉。它还没被发明出来。你看现在美黑涂抹刷已经没有用武之地了，但在当时它本来可以的。当时有这种需求，显然喷雾满足了这种需求，但是。还有防晒棒。我很喜欢防晒棒。对，我懂。现在有很多解决方案，但我带你回到20世纪90年代，当时除了黏糊糊的防晒霜外，这些东西都不存在，而我们在解决一个问题。而且，我们脑海里甚至有整段电视广告，整段电视购物广告
because, you know, who else could use it? Maybe older people who need to apply, you know, lotions because they have arthritis. Right. Or maybe they've lost range of motion and they can't reach some places. Well, that was the other great thing about the tan baster. It was like a back scratcher. It could go down your back. See, tan baster. I think the name was part of the problem. Why? Because every time you say tan baster, I just think of a turkey on Thanksgiving. Okay. All brown and crinkly with gravy. Let me take you back to the 1990s. This was again, before we kind of knew about sun damage so much. No, no, no, no. Because you based a turkey. I know. And you based your body. You're going to get nice and tan if you use the tan baster.
因为，你知道，还有谁能用它？也许是需要涂抹防晒乳的老年人，因为他们有关节炎。对。或者也许他们活动范围受限，有些地方够不着。好吧，美黑涂抹刷另一个伟大之处在于它就像一个不求人。它能伸到你背後。看，美黑涂抹刷。我觉得名字本身就是问题的一部分。为什么？因为每次你说美黑涂抹刷，我只想到了感恩节的火鸡。好吧。又棕又皱还带着肉汁。让我带你回到20世纪90年代。这同样是在我们对防晒损伤了解得没那么多的时候。不，不，不，不。因为你要给火鸡刷油。我知道。而你要给你的身体刷油。如果你用了美黑涂抹刷，你会晒得很漂亮
You know what I'm saying? This is when people wanted that. Right. They weren't into sunblock for the SPF. Right. This is when you were still basically applying baby oil to yourself. With iodine. Going in the sun. Yeah. Right. I don't know. I'm just saying. Okay. Well, very passionate. The toilet buddy, the tan baster. Stacey, I'm sorry. We never got it off the ground. Oh, well. Stacey, somewhere you guys have a sketch of the tan baster and I'd love to see it. We do have a sketch of the tan baster. You know, I've been trying to work that tan baster into a lot of projects for you and I. Lady, we're not going to have an office lady's tan baster. It's just not happening. Okay. You know what I want? Before we do a tan baster, I want a rosé.
你知道我在说什么吗？这是人们想要那个的时候。对。他们涂防晒霜不是为了防晒指数。对。这是你基本上还在往自己身上抹婴儿油的时候。加上碘酒。去晒太阳。 yeah。对。我不知道。我只是说说。好吧。嗯，真有激情。马桶好伙伴，美黑涂抹刷。斯黛西，我很抱歉。我们没能让它问世。哦，好吧。斯黛西，你们某个地方一定有一张美黑涂抹刷的草图，我很想看一看。我们确实有一张美黑涂抹刷的草图。你知道，我一直试图把那个美黑涂抹刷塞进你我的很多项目中。女士，我们不会做什么办公室女士美黑涂抹刷的。这根本不可能发生。好吧。你知道我想要什么吗？在我们做美黑涂抹刷之前，我想要一杯桃红葡萄酒。
Okay. I think more of us would use the rosé. Let's put a poll out there. No. What do you want more? An office lady's rosé or an office lady's tan baster? I got to go with tan baster. I knew you were going to say it, Sam. I knew it. Why'd you think I was going to say it? Novelty. No, because a lot of the sprays and sticks have harmful chemicals in them, like aerosols and things that are bad for you. Cassie. I'm team rosé. Yeah. Always going to try one. Well, you know what? Let's drink rosé while we baste ourselves. Is it possible to baste rosé into my mouth? Hey. Rosé baster. Perhaps. Oh, my word. Where are we? Oh, you guys, we got to check back in with Kevin and Lynn. We do because poor Kevin has been receiving a lot of advice this
好吧。我觉得我们更多的人会用桃红葡萄酒。我们搞个投票吧。不。你更想要什么？办公室女士的桃红葡萄酒还是办公室女士的美黑涂抹刷？我选美黑涂抹刷。我早就知道你会这么说，山姆。我早就知道了。你为什么觉得我会这么说？新奇。不，因为许多喷雾和防晒棒含有有害化学物质，比如气溶胶和对你不好的东西。凯茜。我是桃红葡萄酒队的。耶。总是想尝试一个。好吧，你知道吗？让我们一边涂抹防晒一边喝桃红葡萄酒吧。把桃红葡萄酒涂抹进我嘴里可能吗？嘿。桃红葡萄酒涂抹刷。也许吧。哦，天哪。我们在哪？哦，伙计们，我们得去看看凯文和林了。我们必须去，因为可怜的凯文一整集
whole episode. And guess what? When he finally does meet up with Lynn in the parking lot, he does just fine being Kevin. He says, I'm just going to say everything I'm thinking. She has a great smile. He'd like to take her for dinner and a movie. She says yes. He's happy. And then he says boobs. And she's delighted. Yeah. Lynn just likes Kevin. Yeah. Like you said, there's a lid for every pot. There is. Dwight's advice to Kevin was just go be alive next to her. Well, it worked. And finally, we have our tag, a final knock, knock joke, a ding dong joke, really. Yeah. We talked about this with Rain. This one is so hilarious because Dwight thinks he's going to get Jim back and he does ding dong. And then Jim's like, you know what? I just got out of
都在接受各种建议。你猜怎么着？当他终于在停车场遇到林时，他做凯文做得非常好。他说，我要说出我脑子里的所有想法。她笑得很甜。他想带她去看晚餐和电影。她答应了。他很高兴。然后他说胸部。而她很高兴。耶。林就是喜欢凯文。对。就像你说的，锅配锅，盖配盖。确实。德怀特给凯文的建议就是去她旁边活着。好吧，它管用了。最后，我们的彩蛋，一个最终的敲门笑话，一个叮咚笑话，真的。是的。我们和雷恩讨论过这个。这个太搞笑了，因为德怀特以为他能捉弄到吉姆，他去按了门铃。然后吉姆就说，你知道吗？我刚洗完澡
the shower. I need one second. And then like we talked about, they go back and forth with like, well, I can come back. When's good for you? It's like so ridiculous. And that is golden ticket. We hope you enjoyed. I loved this episode. I did too. And thank you, Rainn Wilson, for coming on our podcast. That just gave me all the warm fuzzies for the whole day. I really do want us to go over there. You know, we have an office text thread. We've talked about this. We're the cast text each other and we have all invited ourselves over to Rainn. So Rainn, and sorry, Holly, we're coming. We are. You know, you told us sometime after Labor Day. Well, it's after Labor Day. Guess who remembered the date you told her? That's right. Of course. I want to
我需要一秒钟。然后就像我们讨论的那样，他们一来一回地说，嗯，我可以回来。什么时候方便？这简直太荒谬了。这就是金奖券。我们希望你们喜欢。我很喜欢这一集。我也是。谢谢雷恩·威尔逊来我们的播客。这让我一整天都感到暖洋洋的。我真的很想让我们去那儿。你知道，我们有一个办公室短信群。我们讨论过这个。我们演员之间会发短信，我们都自作主张邀请自己去雷恩家。所以雷恩，对不起，霍莉，我们要去了。真的。你告诉过我们在劳动节之后的某个时候。好吧，现在是劳动节之后。猜猜是谁记住了你告诉她的日期？没错。当然。我想
go. Well, guys, we will see you next week. Please check out Rainn's podcast, Metaphysical Milkshake with Reza Aslin. We love you. Love you guys. Have a great one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolfe, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
去。好吧，伙计们，我们下周见。请查看雷恩的播客，与礼萨·阿斯兰一起的《玄学奶昔》。我们爱你们。爱你们，伙计们。祝你们过得愉快。谢谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是凯茜·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡皮树》。要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。在Stitcher Premium免费试用一个月，请使用优惠码 OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。